The Fortnite Battle Pass, I just shit on my head
Then I boot it off my PC, cause I need me to get the Fortnite Battle Pass
Good morning, good evening, and good afternoon my little weflins
We are playing this redonkulous game that is known as Fall Guys
Sorry if you had to download the bottom thing cause of me, but thank you for downloading the thing cause of me
This game is called Fall Guys, but we have dubbed it the Jelly Bean Game
Just wanna start off the stream by announcing some terrible fucking news
Oh gee, for any membership stream today, they'll watch longer than 90 the museum
Unfortunately I'm gonna have to reschedule it in a couple of days time
Because I was born with this curse of being a fucking woman
I'm fucking tired and I'm really sick right now, unironically
How did I get you guys in here? Oh fuck it's been so long since I've played this
How did I get you in? Oh no
Is it?
Explore, no I want custom game
I wanna host the custom game, this will create a private lobby, yes
Control, control
Oh right, okay, wait, game selector? Oh no it's been so long
Oh there's too much
Solo, squad, duo, no solo
Oh there's like tons of different freaking game modes
Right how do I get you in? Do I need to do anything?
You guys are connecting? Okay, six, delta, Vigo, five, bravo
Pick solos, okay I have to pick, sorry, sorry
It's been, okay okay it filled up, it filled up right okay
It shows me that we need 40, or it goes as high as 40
Okay, no you're not to let me win, hold on let me go
Of course I've not gone on freaking, see this live chat top chat nonsense
Vigo, yeah, I forgot what V is, vector? I think vector in the alphabet
It's okay, oh it's been a fucking terrible week
I didn't wanna be one of those VTubers that are like I'm a ketchup packet, I'm a fucking ketchup packet
I'm so bloody tired of it, I'm exhausted
Yesterday I was like up ed in the Freya collab, like the subtitles on it
To make the video, and my heart was murmuring away over and over and over
And I'm like you need to calm down, like I'm tired, please
And like I've just woken up and my heart was murmuring again
So I'm currently drinking a fucking fruit smoothie, I've got a cup of tea
I can't play on US servers, no you need to swap to US servers
I mean we can resolve that issue for a while, you'll have to wait until October and then you can do it okay
Pop, pop, pop, pop
Do it for my birthday, how about that
Meow, meow, meow
I'm gonna be learning the controls as you go along
Wait what?
Almost typed the code into the chat because I forgot how controllers were interacted
You're so fucking adorable, oh my god look at my weephins coming in
I can't see you guys yet, I just saw something connecting to the server
I wish, didn't I know I used to like zoom out and show all of us together as you guys were coming in
I'm in, hey yeah
I have hard lag on US servers, I mean it's better than Australian servers
I can tell you that much, if I played Oceanic I would be winning because some of the best
Because of the lag
We all pick the same cosmetics so you can't tell who's you're being, you can see as if you expand the player list
Oh my god it's my free flings
You guys really got Xbox and stuff, oh look I can see if you're on Xbox and who's on game
Like who's on PC
Someone new just came in, oh that's so cool
Oh gee I wonder what my gamer tag is, truly a mystery
It's a jelly beanie
I'm gonna join in a bit, I'm too hungry
We need the glasses assets for reasons, glasses? Oh I don't need my, you want my actual glasses?
You can't see, oh you actually can't see this, what the heck?
Oh they must have changed it, I'm currently in Vtrib Studio opening up the files
So it's not displaying for you
I've got black glasses, heart glasses
I've got green heart glasses, I think I'm green heart glasses
No way I have an old asset, no
I've sun glasses, no wait these aren't glasses
I think I'm just gonna have to go with the green one
Oops my bad
Where the heck is it?
Blue, right G, G-A-V-C-D-E-F-G
H-I
Wait how does it already, how does it already know I'm sideways though?
Wait oh my god sorry this is, how does it know I'm sideways?
No, did I do it right?
How is this the best I can do?
Good morning, are you guys at Stony's bread mode where it sounds like a Stan account now?
I tried, is this what you were wanting kinda, oh no it's like blinking with me
Oh that's awful sorry
I just have no luck, wait do I need to make myself bigger and then do it?
Hold on sorry, a giant woman
Hold on, let me try without attaching it to my freaking eyeballs
And then we'll go for game, right
What if it's like sunglasses on?
How does it know I'm already looking sideways?
This is getting freaky honestly
Right and then if I pin it in between
Fuck
I'm not even pinning it to my eyelashes
Why is this so hard?
Right no, no glicks for me, fuck
I can't either, I'm trash
Neglects
Right okay, I'm gonna sit, we're gonna go
I'm gonna make it easier on myself
If I only happen 26 competitors
Oh shit no someone dropped out I think, oops
I'm currently drinking a fruit juice I'm almost finished and then I'll have a cup of tea
I'm like getting all the war
Thank you for the audio you released after the tier list
Lol
Oh no it's been so, oh look at many of you there are little replays
What are we, oh god it's the Rhino one
Wait why can't I see your names?
Last time, no
Oh that's embarrassing
I'm gonna be honest that's actually rather embarrassing to be honest
That was planned but hey ho
That was literally a speedrun
Oh my god of course we got this one first
Kiki Fumbler repping the green
Didi
Do it or did he not let's find out
That fucking Heimer Donger jumped off that map instantly
Oh did he's going to take ninja
Smoothly dodging the rhinoceros
Blank Aelis
Doing his thing
Pakopa just getting, oh got moded down a wee bit
Okay but he's still standing he's still going strong like
As well as Kikurisu
Sol
You need to enable names
Oh there we go I can see all your names now
I was gonna say
I was like I could have sworn I could see all your names not in spectator mode
But fuck say
Literally only ten of us survived
That was such a hard one for our first freaking thing
Literally a princess carry not to get eliminated
No cause that's what happened last time I sucked so bad I was like
We're already on a final round
Right I guess cause I missed like also many of us perished
I got like limited two seconds after
Okay ten reeflings remain in the battle dome
And only one, sorry I just bumped the heck out
And only one can remain
Rune desolation playing it nice and safe
The Kraken is lurking on Lee Wink
But he's not phased at all not even dropping a sweat
Arrow to the Neen
Just doing his thing he's jumping nice and safe he's getting tilted on the board
He jumps onto the yellow side but can Black Ellies make it? He can
Blank sorry not Black
Reykuma jumping over nice and safe two reeflings maybe even hugging each other
Maybe kissing a little
No okay okay
And then we got li li li li li li on his oh no no no no no
The Kraken is smacking down
WWE sale
Chili Blogg's living up to his name by just chilling
Please laugh
Okay thank you I was clicking the button
I'm like please laugh
Rune desolation just jumping through the map
does not care if the kraken tentacles lock onto him lay wink as well just go and zoom in but
did we just witness a reefling massacre i think so and then it's between arrow to the knee and
lay wink fun guy please love oh literally i was like spamming the button i wouldn't come on
you died and now you want us to die to your dad jokes as well
arrow to the knee and lay winks we're touching each other there's grabbing but there's jumping
and the level is over just like that our winner is arrow to the knee unidentified falling object
fantastic first round fantastic reeflings third place is fine oh you guys did amazing that was
over so quickly i don't think oh wait sorry lobby code is six delta vector five bravo i can't join
today but not too nice to mama fellow reeflings also someone grabbed some cake for me smoking face
thank you anon for the tip some cake i've got plenty to go around actually i've already edited
hold on let me finish my fruit juice the first round was brutal brah literally we've got a
decimate is there anyone else that can join in six delta vector five bravo the reeflings will be
nice to me i'm sure they will wink wink there you go the codes in chat okay i finished one
fruit juice do you be getting no heart murmurs for me the asmr today was a surprise i'm keeping
it for stream well i've already got the bonus asmr uh no it's not bonus like the thank you asmr
don't forget to like the stream chat no you've been a better streamer than me
oh don't forget to like and subscribe lads oh i'm fucking shite of that i don't really i
i don't mind i think saying like isn't bad but like although saying that i do that in the asmr so
i can't chat shite it's not bonus i did thigh cupping asmr um but uh so i had to like deal
with the freaking levels right is that everyone in that one's in had i put right no rhino game
oh crap a reefling just came in like that last second um the freaking right we'll go again
don't worry if you're trying to join we can get you in very shortly we're all waiting for one person's
connection right big fans knock out modes eliminate players after each round reach the final and win
the crown congrats on 9k don't let the success get to your head and make you eat higher calorie
oh stop i'm already fucking dying over here heart murmur city but it's fine it's because i'm low on
liquids look at all my oh i can see all your names now okay how do i jump hold on so how do
you jump dive oh a and x okay it's a and x okay just okay a and x a x sorry i'm on xbox so
i don't know what you guys are but i'm an xbox kid
okay we're playing it i'm playing it super safe i don't know about you guys but i'm playing it
super safe it's been a while oh my god that guy that reefling just went for it he's really
like i'm out i've had enough of this world to see us later okay nice and easy i said nice and easy
nice and easy i just threw i just threw
oh my god i actually just
no way i was african had that why was i so greedy
no i'm not gonna make it wait piggyback can i jump on your back what was that
yeah wait can i do it okay maybe i can do it hold on i don't know oh no there's far too many
of you at the finish line already why are you so much better this game than me i'm supposed
to be the game war not you here's our added to offer fucks sake oh wow i actually survived that
i don't know how but i'll take it oh i'm just chasing the freaking thing oh wait no why did it
why i'm sorry i don't know what i'm thinking i'm not waiting good morning good afternoon good
evening i'm strutting uh uh uh uh i'm fucking having a stroke and no it's not the gift came
come on it's terribly in the morning to suck so badly at a video game please it's literally
a child's video game this is always the worst part this is always the worst part and look all
the reflins in the distance celebrating they're like yeah cleared it half an hour ago bro i'm trying
reflins i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming i'm doing it i'm doing it i'm
doing it come back come back come back oh my god thank you for letting me
in literally the second game i have to cheat to get in why am i so bad
it's not possible it is not possible i didn't know you could pick it back wait
don't worry i'm washed off this fuck literally i'm not playing since the last thing we played
together i'm like uh wait can i jump on someone's back can someone offer me their back i'm on the
right side um how do i jump on like it gave so i gave me a symbol to jump on yeah that how do i do
that no my god i forgot what the game mode was i'm so sorry i just killed us all
a refling always goes down with his mummy thank you reflins i'm so sorry i was just curious
about the backpack feature wait i can literally get you to catch princess carrying me through the game
unironically i can sit on your back and you can carry me through sections question mark
i am so down to do that that would be hilarious death from learning honestly i didn't realize
it was a slime crawl uh rilke had miss at the back but he's making it very slowly no pressure
chili bloke oh my god i forgot it's the milia califa song
okay we got it did did he do it apparently so the courts are catching up to that man
salsa barbecue the only thing that is on a roll is him because he's about to make it away
oh no oh no oh no li li li watch this other refling get rolled in the slime he needs to
make it carefully without activating the step traps or he's in big trouble
big big trouble he's the last one on the map can he do it look out for the swing and keep pops
oh he's feyne he's feyne he doesn't need any grabbing them balls like it's fifa
milia califa wait hit or miss i guess he never missed huh
oh wait i'm eliminated i'm like all happy for you oh there's like what's this
pig win pill party knock it i don't recognize this one is this near
oh my god it looks like a little pill place there you have a party at a pill in those american tv shows
oh my god what is this item oh time held
what
oh my gosh wait you have to hold the little dudas
how do you grab again on pc i assume just dive onto it with with x oh on pc sorry
wait pig party hold on a minute he's already have he's already be lined up for me i'm taking a sip
of my tea before it gets too cold fuck it's already too cold oh no every fling you drop the penguin
left trigger for xbox okay i'm gonna remember that i'm totally not panic when i end up in this game
would oh they're going for it can they get it oh they're fighting over the same penguin
who's gonna get it i'm dong i really not giving up he said that penguin main
oh no he's still on the chase oh rilke's i'm yanking it though
oh god king are you a weenie oh you're a golden weenie congrats on your goldenness you're like one
of those uh do you know those videos that are like oh this is gold encrusted food and it's worth
like 1000 and then this is the four dollar version of it that's who you look like you're the thousand
dollar version of a hotdog damn i'm washed don't worry i think we're all washed literally the
yeah like the gold flake videos really this is a four dollar hotdog this is a hundred dollar
gourmet hotdog and this is a thousand dollar hotdog and all they do is put gold on it like edible gold
oh it's hexagon oh we have nine seven reeflings can i count
and they're off honeycombing what are the tactics some reeflings have already jumped below but we
are still in the first yellow quadrant it is being shared dramatically so for those of them
are dropping from the top they may find themselves down a lot deeper than they wanted to be
ah i forgot how good the music is i'm new to the game so that'll be my say yeah i'm new too
never played the game in my life before you know you can't expect everyone to be perfect right off
the bat come on you need to be realistic me come on here we go chili blogs does not get a f oh he was
having the tactics until he gets pushed down due to the nature of other reeflings coming into play
as he falls down and onto the purple but he cannot go anywhere oh my gosh okay we're on the last layer
warning to reeflings above the last layer has been infiltrated on the hexagon chili blogs leaving
no one alive once he's finished wiping he is mopping up them honeycombs although he finds
himself into a bit of trouble with another reefling jumping down with a second reefling coming
into the fray and three reeflings together coming into the fray at the end but he does make his way
over to his own quadrant you did it oh my god we respect hitting the winner this map gives me
anxiety i like an answer we need a voice pack chili blog sanic you did it and you have a master
chief helm let's go gg you guys are so freaking skilled honestly uh lobby code still the same lobby
still the same lobby job i did not expect to last long as i did that's what he said
oh come on one in three men fuck you that was funny
if there's anyone else that wants to come in it's six delta vector five bravo we're just using the
same lobby because it's not full no yeah i don't know what ed a bit cheeky right tail dysfunction
look nah they point being embarrassed about it i'm still downloading the game
you forgot to download in advance didn't i not say another stream to come download it
yeah yeah apparently the statistics for guys is like one in three have a bit of a
but what happened to vego oh we're saying vector now alpha bravo wait hold on alpha bravo charlie
delta echo foxtrot gamma hotel i don't know what comes after age how about we do query and i'll
say the alphabet cuba oh no i don't know it whiskey echo Romeo tango
the fuck is why golf not gamma the for victor ain't no way she's in the military alphabet
apparently i'm mangling it beyond belief yankee oh it is yankee you know what you are
yanking on my
i finished my tea are we ready let's go surely i will win one of them we're playing dizzy heights
press to ask for help or to help someone else dive x on a slippery
surely surely i'm not going to throw what are you talking about you got this one moment heck yeah
one refling jump backwards on to me
right i can do this i'm actually try harden saws i'm actually try harden okay
okay that's fine that's fine i'm doing like the least efficient way possible but it's possible
that's the main thing as long as it i don't have no just stop grabbing me stop it stop it i'm winning
oh yeah the one time i'm actually doing decent you guys will try to hold me back i see how it is
you sabotaging me fuck i'm gonna do a little spin just to prove how it stop grabbing me
oh wait i can't see your names okay now i can see your name so i can show it out
you when you grab at me okay out on my face that was like right on my face and nothing else
ow stop out stop it hurts yes we did it we actually did it for once
wow i knew i could do that one i knew it there we go why we flins that perish
stop taking balls on your feet i just want to carry mommy you let me win the rounds
that's the only way to carry me unless i ask to get put on your back but i don't know how to ask to
do that no wait i was 25 oops tail tag make sure you have a tail when the timer runs out oh no this is
does start with the tail give me that tail how do i know it start with the tail and you do no
fuck you come here give me the head to take it give me a oh shit no no leave me alone leave me
alone i'm just a little furry leave me alone stop stop stop you're stressing me out you're stressing
me out squidward squidy squidy squidward you're stressing me out no give me a bag give me a bag
stop it right you let me wings come here shit right you you come here chair give me give me a
freaking butt plug give me a stop head to grab it wait okay okay i'll just dive into you
no squidward not no squidward no stop it stop taking it from me stop taking what's mine that
was my original tail even though i took it off for me fun wait head that i don't get how it does
it's not freaking coming take it out why is it so freaking like why is your butthole so
freaking puckered i can't take the dang thing shit i'm gonna lose how do i grab it eggs or is it
just i've run into you give me the tail how am i doing so badly am i supposed to press the trigger
get wait hold on wait no you give it to me wait how did you take it back no i'm not playing
not no i'm out of time give me the butt plug i did it i did it i take the reefless butt plug
and shoved in me i give it nowhere that periflans violated after that honestly
or is it by me
sharing is caring honestly hoverboard heroes
oh oh no have i played this before i don't recognize the name too much
oh wait are we on the hoverboard already you're not supposed to pull it out so violently
i hit are you squidding me right there what did i do strony you wouldn't be master chief
master chiefs which makes you infinitely more powerful colon nondiscord angle
whoa what the fuck is going on thank you so much narrow for the super chat wait what am i doing
are we just trying to survive
wait can i jump on you
ow no reflux reflux oh i wasn't paying attention i'm so sorry did anyone get walloped off the map
there i don't do it i don't sorry i'm not paying attention hold on
we must stay focused reeflings we must wait how do you
i need to pay attention to the map because i keep not paying attention because i'm getting
so distracted i'm pressing you guys yeah that's right i'll just blame it on you guys
oh reeflings you had me so distracted i was trying to jump on your backs but it wasn't working
oops that was my bad honestly
that was my bad i'm not this smart we've got zink he jumping he a little jumping avocado
any free shuffle
oh
for your risk made it okay okay i did better than me this game i'm a go oh i was a go talk dog
it's all our fault you have to hit up on the d-pad to grab
wait i'm a i'm a at the start of the next round i'm gonna practice all the controls on you guys
and start grabbing yous and jumping on your backs is because i'm being rubbish
you know she's having fun which gets to forgets to censor herself monkaist wait what am i saying
am i not being good ah the freaking writing stream got limited ads and i don't want to like
go against the oh the cracking again i volunteer as tribute
okay looks like rune is going to get rid of all the pallets to get up the tentacles right away
furious is being chilling vk sweat clapper what name
oh how did you even get there
okay oh wow it's already between three refunds already sweat clapper ruin or furious
jump on me that's when you know the writing's good i mean you said but
but somebody said is there something really wrong with that huh huh was the normal human
behavior to be exploratory huh are you squid me right now train at the beginning of next round
you can take that for free thank you broly like oh sweatclap oh well our victor has been decided
for this round it's not no no they're furious clap clap clap clap clap clap thank you broly legend
for the tip you could have taken that for free you know okay the lobby code is still the same
six delta victor five bravo
i don't even know what kicked me in the air gg i think the cracking tentacle can shove you up
uh maybe a a thingy my bobber
chatting is free uh barrel is chatting is free literally you can say stuff for
free you know that right and i tell you what you know when i make that short that goes like oh
how much the vtuber is making a month and then i show the actual money just know it's because of you
fanies that refuse to take something for free and chat and give me money for it just know it's
because of you guys that the amount looks so humongous because you guys can't stop meming on
me and dunking on me honestly the crack it is so fitting for this stream honestly i am at work
sad oh no you know how time to play wait is this not a week did i not pick a week end to play put
this on what i poor thank you for the five gifted members and fiendish with the exact same time in
what the heck are you doing are you married you should kiss thank you for the 10 gifted what
and a pentane one thank you for the super chat chat is free i'll stop right okay kfp is
fighting thank you for the super chat as well no seriously when i reveal how much i've earned in
my first month right these are done we're going in the next game rake come on thank you broly legend
thank you user chat right user done user done we're playing speed sliders okay
we're playing speed sliders i love free super chats yes brian
it's shocking these are actually done oh it's a slip and slide one okay reeflings um just go just
go just go don't hang about go go go go go look at us all on our bellies
oh my belly's so airy air my belly is so aerodynamic like look at me go honestly i've
got freaking nothing like oh look at that turn oh big jump big jump reefling
wow the speed boost call me let's see oh wow oh my god i love this one so much
oh we're bumping heads we're bumping heads but it's okay there's enough room for two of us on
this track i think we might be ahead i don't want to jinx it but i think we're gonna do it i think
we're gonna do it what did she say was free talking you dumb dumb wow okay let's get more of that
please chat for the free price of 1.99 you can also chat that's not how it works thank you chat
jeez you guys are so silly boobily thank you out for being just for the gifted and congrats
all those people that caught it please enjoy the most uh azura emotes have been ordered i repeat
azura emotes have been ordered and straw knee emotes have been ordered you're gonna see the
return of some many very loved emotes okay for straw knee in particular literally just sent
the mold stuff out right here can i can i get this please free turner man brian turner man both
the air now oh my god when i show my freaking earnings from my the first month of hold on i need
to try hard what am i doing i don't know oh oh what am i doing oh i don't really remember this one
well but i think i have done it before so that's the good news hold on let me try hard hold on
any sweat i need to win i need to win you don't understand this is how i get my tiddly
winks of serotonin oh my head it's okay though it's okay though okay i'm a bit slow but i'm
getting there i'm getting there oh my goodness hold on i need like a heart rate monitor on to
like prove how freaking intense it i just made it oh my god i just made it narrow and turner man
thank you for the super chat what do you mean you're cooking and we got to try the piggyback
we do not when it's the slip and slide on the first one though are you squidding me right now
free chats for mama riefling sassafras thank you for the tip seriously oh i put right
yous are done yous are actually done i'm not being funny i think i made like what three thousand
us dollars on youtube and then stream elements was like some insane number i can't remember what
stream elements was hi dempa broly legend how dare you wait what am i to do i wasn't paying attention
what are they doing ow i just got run by a ball help i don't know what i'm doing can i jump on
someone's back no yeah no no i'm not gonna keep you alive i'm not gonna keep you alive i don't
know how to keep you alive in this game mode oh god they're i don't know if i can keep you alive
low refunds oh no there's the slimes down there oh run wait who oh we're getting rolled over
rieflings i'm worried
oh my god right save me save me riefling do not if you let us die you're getting timed out that's
all i'm saying you're getting timed out not for 10 seconds for a whole minute if you make me perish
on your back you have died wait what did i not done just connect to you okay there we go right
you're getting timed out if you get me killed do i make myself clear oh wow you actually did it
i don't get what gets demonetized or not at all oh literally
i feel like beg youtube please review this video there's nothing wrong with it you can
read backs now yeah can't let mommy lose oh this is like mario party wait you can do this in mario
party is it like a connect with chat game can't play with reeflings on mario party question mark
i ain't really played much nintendo i have to admit dempa i think her ace toy was legit i didn't
wait no dempas thing got limited ads i didn't get taken down though it's lord of storms thank you
you i can't jump oh no no no reefling you can't be on my back for this one because i need to be
able to jump on your head you're gonna get bonked from the top thing
i'd play but i don't think i've ever played it
did you see our ace mars doing so well dempa people love the freaky alien girls infecting them
with a symbiote i can't believe it the people are freaks your honor but the good kinds
hi johnny hi we're playing jellybean game if you want to join i show the code every lobby
oh no i didn't enjoy that at all please don't make me do that again
i don't know if it's maybe better to jump into the dang thing you know that
oh sugar or maybe not i don't know is there a tactic to these game woods or sometimes that
really just luck like that was terrible timing oh shoot oh i may have to play mario party with
you but i don't know if everyone has a nintendo switch those things are expensive she says that
so she sits on a pc rig eat these tactic me i don't want to throw i don't want to throw anyway
so is this stream where you hypnotize everyone to sacrifice themselves no it's not gonna happen
i already know what happened last time now that i am dead i love the club between you two
every so fun dempa was such a good sport basically she'd be in dempa or kill you with
each other and i was like hi dempa i'm stroney smile i want to do ASMR smile and she was like
yeah i was like oh shit that was she's like so nice what the heck and then boom the rest is history
and now there's alien girls infect you ASMR on my channel because of how ouch i just bumped my elbow
because of how awesome dempa is oh yeah oh also dempa we met your i would say your rig papa but
it was a itchy girlfriend she came in here and she was like i rigged dempa and i was like you
rigged dempa because dempa was telling me she made her own art and i was like oh she can flex on
everyone now sacrifice for me there's also crab game yes i definitely give crab game because it's
free i'm pretty sure um can the reeflings solid blake more like solid attempt again bobbing
and weaving he's being careful kick kirus oh no rune getting absolutely smacked back down the
ramp of slime i had oh it's a vehicle for something 100% oj is a good party game but it's four player
oh
yeah i drew an edgy girlfriend rig yeah she came in she was like i made dempa and i was like wait what
and i was like it's a family reunion up in here that is good because i've got a cheeky ASMR collab
with the edgy girlfriend coming in it it should do jack box stream with vealer girl no we had so
much fun we will we probably will um the group collabs already been decided for this month but
there's a few more one-on-one collapse i've got a collab with azura coming up and i'm excited
she says she's very dumb and it's a puzzle game wink wink fulmin the final round
dempa hasn't had a chance to see the garlic phone collab that was chaos in a ball
yes she's my papa and i'm my mama gives birth to self ASMR with proof okay we've got seven
brieflings if i can count properly climbing up this hill we've already got a bit of a split going on
solid Blake is really hugging the right side will this pay off for him we do not know yet
lee wink is getting lee up this hill um he's doing quite well he's often to actually hug
the left side instead two opposites of the same coin i don't know what i'm trying to say
duh wait who the right side tactic clearly worked what the heck congrats solid Blake
that was so quick i was freaking just getting started on the commentary i was trying to make it
close you already finished the dang thing hi terry uh master chief reefling is actually two of me
okay yeah you can buy this shirt this and jack box that'd be cute
hammer cost me the crown gg well played okay the lobby code is six delta vector five bravo
any brothers yeah
yeah sorry i thought today was a weekend for some reason maybe it is for Australians
and my brain was like hmm yes yes quiet oh my god we're about to have a full lobby oh mommy's so
sorry just pin the lobby code yeah i guess if we aren't cycling out of it hold on
huh i do not have
hold on hold on let me open up my we stream okay hold on hold on i know you can't hear nothing
right what is it u.s west west server oh i had caps lock on i'm sorry was it six delta vector
five bravo yeah oh god that looks so scuffed you know what if it wasn't scuffed it wasn't me
how do you us west servers okay there we go i'll be ready i'm so close to joining and
it's saturday for stroney it's friday for everyone else us folk haven't finished rough
that was a bit of an oversight from me i apologize oh is it full sorry i think i'm
going to drop out whoopsie sorry so he said for veiler plushies to be a thing i won't be
heart actually i need to message a contact for now for no reason at all
can the last three fling get in or we or we fill it the in
are you squidding me right now oh what all yorkers in chat say hi are you yorking your pentas
thank you your free papa for the super chat
oh happy fourth of july oh happy america day america hi y'all
congrats on independent hi
hi
wait why are we all saying hi it's july fifth as hackers say i'm in the little it was yesterday
oh all right that's why you're all saying hi because of your free papa okay got it got it
papago i got it i got it okay because everyone's jork you can't be jorking it right now we're jelly
beans gotta be flicking it i already forgot okay roll out in between rotating i can't read that
fast you think i can read that fast but right who's back on my jumping on who's good at this game
let me on your back who's good at the game whoa oh oh no we can't know on this one uh
oh i don't like this oh i don't like this no sorry no sorry no sorry i did not play this i just
saw that riflin perished in his wee grave oh gosh why is this speed not don't do that you're making me
nervous if you get motion sick i don't think this map is for you actually i'm like trying to think
in terms of like would this make mercy sick if she who is watching this right now i like yeah
that would make her sick okay okay okay okay aim bot aim bot wait are like ledges of that fallen off
it must be oh oh no whoa not good not good at all oh dear okay how do we need oh no i'm not gonna
make it i'm actually not gonna make it i don't think no that's why i don't know why i did that please
brain please i need four more reeflings to perish into the hot slime below oh come on
oh come on i can do it i'm so smart i'm so smart i can outmit every these reeflings come on i've
got the best connection here oh i've made a mistake right get back on here oh thank goodness
oh no everyone is in the lobby at playing with joystick
that's terrible i mean for that time i was gonna have a gamer girl called joystick come on i'm still
i still think that's the best name ever sorry i actually do yeah the game's free go mommy go go
mommy go i would perish in sturdy slime for real for real you'd be drowning in it drowning in it
what was that meme where it was like squidward it was like when english people say there's a drone
present and then a squidward going drowning in it like drowning in it and then it sounds like
drone in it like in it bro what are we doing count the fruit count the fruit are you joking
i don't see the numbers
what do you mean stand on the answer what
i said count the fruit and there was no numbers
am i going mental
it was the screen was the question oh i thought i was gonna be like there was four foot on the thing
bro i had like no time to react so it tells you what
three what oh right okay i get it now oh
okay i get it now but that was like bro you can't actually count the fruit and then no ask for how
many fruit were on the board total so as i said what i said i didn't you know i believe he's done
yeah that was rough okay we've played it now so at least we know how it works
oh oh no
i didn't understand in time either literally i was like where's the numbers on the bomb
smile i got ruled by my own game okay i'll behave next time we have a multiplayer game i'll make
sure it's on a weekend that was an oversight by me because of time zones like whenever i post
like oh this is the week schedule i'm already in monday on sunday if that makes sense so my full
week schedule is like already complete by the time you see like the next one
how many one two three four five six seven eight eight reef flings but only one will be crowned
the champion well cheers trying to knock out absolutely everything in one go
i'm probably legendary knocking out the blues again solid Blake working on the blues so
it's blank you were the one that was chasing me from my tail how dare you reef flings getting up
and squidy it's corny real cad was kind of half lagging out half not question mark or maybe it's
me it's probably me sassan for us a croco deal like lining croco the snack snacky snack pick
oh three reef flings have been eliminated already solid Blake uh maybe up for a second
i so sorry i jinxed you i'm so sorry cheers the winner
oh look at you look at all oh that's right you won yeah that's right you celebrate don't look shy
you own it chair you won congrats chair commentators curse i'm sorry i'm sorry
shout out to all my chairs i messed up i knocked out a full row how dare you
eutime friendly community games are nice yes i just need to pick the weekend when people aren't
at work like a dumb dumb that was me i overlooked that i'm sorry i heard you call my name out and
i got nervous i said putting you guys off when i see your name in stream best day of my life for
real for real yeah are you still filling the lobby so it's quite you are still filling the lobby so
it's quite impressive i am you know what else i can fill not a not a that's not a replaying
i can fill a crack in the wall with silicon yeah i can fill your crack with silicon
hey that's right yeah it was good we're we're big let's go
one doesn't fill holes with silicon what do you do with plaster the clam is pretty easy to fill
bro not this clam just cast men crack on reefing he'll be fine
mm i've been thinking a bit more about my alternative outfit i am a hundred percent
having you up my and like your little uh tentacles wrapping around my thighs and that i do not care
i absolutely do not care how degenerative i it's just meta everyone'd be like why do you not have
like reefing like on your model like with the toggle and i'd be like oh you're already looking
at reefing right now i'm like ready to buy concept art like right now and get it done
i really want to see oh it's a bit of a tight squeeze but we'll make it we'll make it it's
fine it's fine it's about the tight squeeze ow okay it's fine it's fine right let's see
what the deal you always with this boink here no right i made it i made it that's all that
matters i made it sorry i try so hard on the first round i need to prove myself okay i need to prove
myself best decision is the best part third let's go look at my reefing
it was a tight squeeze with all of us together things got slippery fast
lily li oh my memory serves me correct this is my most hated one because i can't understand
how it's supposed to work ebe
okay i'll just turn into a zura to blind all you guys and be like huh and then you'll let me win okay
and today we are playing fall guys together and i am going to win i can do this okay i can do this
hold a to bounce continually i can do it i can do it i can do it i can do it i know
why it's a bit oh my gosh okay okay a lot of refluence fell down it's fine it's not just me
oh i'm stuck okay okay it's fine it's fine i can do it i can do it i can do it if i really
want i can do it what
okay okay okay okay we're doing it we're doing it oh we're doing it we did the hard part
oh oh oh oh gosh okay it's fine it's fine it's fine i did it oh jeez louise oh my god
i don't really suck on that one
holey moley i normally do so terrible i love the bouncy noises in this game honestly
first try i didn't slip once
that was so good can kiki fumbler do it too come on kiki oh you're so close
i must have hit it at the like perfect oh level over
you were blazing through that last part literally i'm so proud of myself i'm like me
how is all me
oh no i'm not the best at rollin i'll try my best are you squidding me right now
you didn't say a message thank you for the super chat room desolation you didn't get
brian to say anything brian to the one reflin that's called brian he just jerk in it sorry
i'm a bit hyper today it's because i'm playing with you again it makes me always like super
hyper like even if i don't feel oh wait this is different we're getting fruit blasted on us
oh no
oh
i'm scared of the fruit
wow i'm just gonna play it super safe in between here and just hope that a few
reflins get knocked off and then i it doesn't have to turn into a tussle
can't even see if that was a flat surface or not i was like oh i'm in trouble here likes
hold on i'm sweating i'll try harding okay two reflings have gone down
i'm next i'm next okay okay okay relax relax it's called humor relax no flake it's called
dark humor replace the h in heart with an f
okay hold on i'm actually try harding so much three reflins are down come on
come on come on these cannons no grabbing
okay four reflings are down i just need four more to go down and we're
oh
that's it we're we're singing the haunted mansion ost from sonic heroes to distress
oh gosh come on four more reflins have to go down just not me though
oh that count is a reflin yeah no i just kind of strum our oh oh no i'm gonna be sick i'm
actually starting to get sick on this one what the heck is it because i had fruit
oh i'm not gonna make it oh my god i'm getting so i'm getting so turned around
hey strony you like playing with those reflins tell me more what i do i like playing stream
snipe game i already know what game we're playing next week and it doesn't require an install
yeah strony getting sick because fruit's being loved are that was disorientating me
debate news and data to keep watching the stream when i go on a road trip
no no save data for something else i'm just me man i'm just i'm just binchening
honestly paying fall guys with the splatoon ost is the best way to play it i have never
played splatoon maybe i should i don't know if it's because it's an ink game
oh i should have got a custom toggle the inks oh i just go like that and then the screen goes
all black like in mario kart when the ink does this thing rub belly mummy's belly oh wait i'm
alive oh no i have to play on my way wait we can talk to each other how do you do how do you do that
oh sorry i'm not paying attention wait how do you talk on my way i need help
careful of the cannons refling the cannons to the right
okay careful right i need to grab oh how'd i grab hold on you practice grabbing wait how
did i grab you is that grabbing is left trigger grabbing oh don't kill me don't kill me okay hold
on i just need to grab on to this i don't know what button is i should go hold on i'm sure i can
figure this out i'm blaming stormy for that first round knockout talking about that alternate
outfit isn't fair lol i had to jump on this am i being pepega no i don't know how to do it
anonymous thank you for the tip version i'm talking about the alternative outfit isn't fair
why you don't like the idea of me sitting on you shocking i want to do i want to get a comic strip
where i accidentally sit on you and i have no idea where you went and you're like obviously on my boat
you can check what the key findings are how dare you suggest something so smart
if you like games with ink i suggest you pay bendy and the ink machine
is that a real game or did you just make that up that sounds like a made-up game
oh you like ink that's right go play schwaubelmobel and the ink machine thank you veal or lover for
the super chat oh it's a real game okay what kind of game it's a horror game
oh no i mean i have a heart rate monitor and i have a uh shock collar on the way
um i've i've asked if any of the girls want their uh if any of the girls want my shock collar
um we have scrumptious night we have leo ink we have chair we have dust fantasy god king air
solely oh no something like that doody uh sit and ink and that's how rooflings are i've missed
one i think apparently um yes i have heart rate monitor now i also have a shock collar um i have
a very interesting shock collar stream coming up um i'll be a slight blast to the past for a few years
but um the punishment is if i lose i have to shock myself i had to get a freaking dog collar
because obviously a dog collar isn't gonna fucking ask for your buddy ip address location name
date of birth and all that whereas like this fucking chinese one did um so i've said to the girls
i was like if anyone wants the shock collar for content i'll send it to you but just warning
you that it takes your data and like the app takes your data as well and um yeah basically
that's the trade off if you want a free collar you unfortunately have to give this app your thing
but yeah i yeah the only thing i could get was a dog collar because it's not gonna ask for my
freaking ip address um why does it take your data uh china is set up a bit differently
like if you ever order anything from china you have whoa
this song is so good sorry the whole thing just died off there we've got three leaflings left
oh i'm sorry i've jinxed it oh okay well taken strong in front of all kids
i feel like emi would love it emi's already got one shibi's already got one so i don't
know if ac0 or mersey want to if they don't want it it's getting shoved in the bin but yeah china's
goods are kind of set up slightly different from our usual wait you don't trust the chinese communist
i'm like why the heck um why the heck that i have to give you a phone number to zap myself
remotely and um i was like looking into the app and it scrubs all your personal data it like scrubs
your phone contacts and stuff and i'm like no why would i need that to administer a little bit of
shocky poos on myself no yeah literally thousand minus thousand social credit unironically though
i can't imagine shibi shocking herself emis but not shibi i thought shibi already got one
shibi already she bought the same one that i've got or i've got the same one that she got
do you not want an extra 300 to your social credit score for boosting the economy
we've already sold my private data it's already gone there's some guy called jimping that's terrible
sorry that was a bad joke everything needs an app nowadays the data harvesting is real if it's free
you're the product yeah i still had to pay for the software so wamp wamp or is it hardware sorry
wamp wamp stroney do you want to hear a german doc oh dark joke steady on dem stay down
stroney it's the feds we've determined from the way you've been using your shock collar that you
may be involved in terrorist activity excuse me what did he say thank you dem stay down for the
super chat that way i have to thank you for that uh how long you be streaming and i have another hour
to go so please don't worry you can download the game oh hold on i'm being pega you can download
the game uh and still get a chance to play just for the members who are waiting on the watch along
unfortunately i'm not very well uh due to the curse of being no oh oh i can respond i still
have a chance oh no i don't all the reflins are gonna make it before me drat okay it's fine it's
fine it's fine glories run them over stroney i i glories i understand yes stroney um it's okay
it's okay i'm still happy i just get to play with you so don't worry don't worry i'm just blabbing away
take some rest yeah no watch along to date no i'm gonna delay another day i think tomorrow i'll
feel better i don't i don't know if it really grosses you guys out or not like i don't wanna
i don't know i'm a ketchup packet i don't know what to say ovulation soon tm but i'm a ketchup
packet right now i'm fucking ill i've not had any heart murmurs though since i've had some liquid
so it's going better or already doing better that's it everyone drop out for stroney no
thank you broly legend for giving the refling some advice
excuse me just got some spit in my throat broly legend advice thank you thank you for the super
oh no oh shortcut okay that's actually really good for shortcut for the crocodile
we love you even if you are afflicted by womanhood oh bravo honestly at least at least the symbol of
ketchup season is like okay ovulation soon i'm about to get h word on the alt account you guys
aren't ready for it um i do have an update about fansly it is august oh sorry i'm not supposed to
say the website name like that you know what fansly is august for everyone everyone's getting
access in august um we had to delay a bit just to focus a bit more in establishing ourselves um
and a few you know plans on the background obviously it would be very nice if all the girls
turn what do gta and the third dry have in common if you have a star you will be pursued
oh my god
i never how about brian i never got that until i got that brian iron report thank you for that
why the fuck would you give a hundred and say that are you squiddin me right now that
mama may we have some for our throats too some more liquid spit i've already forgotten what the
subject was barrow thank you barrow iron reaper right right iron reaper you're literally relaxed
no flick is called dark humor no more jokes like that but thank you for the 100 that was insane
why are 100 though oh i've not played this map no
i don't think i've played this with you
i would have got a chance to play it right i'm gonna put us in teams i don't know what the teams are but
the music yep oh my god the music is you guys saying yes to me because you never say no to me
it just sounds like someone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i did say dark humor to be fair you did so i'll give you that yeah there's like a team
game or something that we can play together so we'll try teams so
oh no oh you're alive i thought you're perished
oh my god this sounds so much like crazy frog sorry
it's not the crazy rough
who makes these songs for this game it's insane sorry but it's like actually good i'm i don't
want to say kids game this is actually good music i managed to dodge the monthly debuff by
respecting into the woman glass later in the game oh what does that mean my respect in
that's funny as fuck we will say it as many times as it uh-huh we want you to take care of your
health more than we want membership streams you already quadruple the typical amount of streams
members get i'm still blown away like people don't do that much change goods and services
thank you miss morgan for the spec is actually such a good thing uh rilke kadmus thank you
no thank you for understanding i don't want to be weird about it but i'm like rough i get really sick
when i so obviously i've streamed from who goes about is like food not everyone
mate you're done iron repert you're done thank you for the tip you're done no more you're done
you're done because you're gonna start me on a tinfoil hat rant
i was something with a sentence like that i'm gonna start me on a tinfoil hat rant what if i told you
you know that's the whole point like you stream for one week 10 hours per day because you're crazy
i don't know why you feel bad i guess it's just like because i know my dad's um getting here very
soon like then it really will be like i can't i can't be like right let's play only two hours of
baltrow wink wink and then end up with five hours like i know i can't do that when he gets here
and it's going to be like that for a little while like oh my god is there someone called day
worst player over there oh no notorious or your chithulu oh no you're literally called yourself
day worst player all this is that we can finally catch up on the vod back logs oh honestly
like last time it's really fucking actually sorry this is me just going on a rant about
being a woman in general it's really annoying because one month ketchup season can not be that
bad and then another like this month for example i'm like completely knocked on my ass like i feel
so ill um like literally my wee heart can't it it doesn't feel good like i don't feel well
i feel lightheaded i feel sick or that and then like the next thing i'll just be like no it's fine
i was like oh okay then because like i literally obviously i streamed for the full month in june
um so i streamed you know during that time and like i was absolutely fine and you wouldn't even
be able to tell what stream i was on you know you know what i'm saying i've heard that can affect it
too if you don't get enough iron yes i basically eat steak once a month to try and replenish my
iron so i get to have steak so at least um my dad's gonna cook it for me i'm sorry but i like
well done steaks i said what i said dinny give me a raw steak dinny give me a blue steak that
hangs that hangs still breathing if you give me a blue steak that's disgusting that's disgusting
okay we're here for well done steaks uh i am caveman eat meat okay caveman eat meat understand
go medium that thing is raw but that that still has eggs from the worms inside it no well done
eliminates any doubt of that sauce but um and it is i need to stay plump you know the booty cheeks
have to be clapable at any moment moment for you when you when you clap into me i want you to be
able to hear clap clap medium 140 kills the eggs yeah and you know what well done does
absolutely just does that delicious this worms just give it texture do not take for the next 10
seconds do you understand me beefling for making me read that out loud strony you're the one that's
done you're done no you're well done wait is this christmas map this is a christmas map
overnight oh my god i can't wait to spend christmas with you it's gonna be so fun
and everything well done makes it tough though i don't mind the chewing i think if you get a
good steak it doesn't really chew like that oh the charcoal gives it texture charcoal like a grill
cookie baking stream you want a bacon stream i can do a bacon stream i've got a really interest
in handcam a some more street who won no way the two-time champion chair you did it twice
congrats that was a full finish that was fantastic
is the steak not grilled it's in a pan question mark a bacon oh you want me to just make bacon
on the stream you don't want like i don't know cookies or something i'll just let you know that
rare medium and all that crap was just an excuse for restaurants to turn out food faster
cooking steak well done yet jussie is an art yeah literally gg of course you're saying gg won
handcams are quite good yes i have a very interesting handcam asmr stream i'm very
interested to see how it's received and i might do a membership asmr which is a bit more
annoying i wouldn't mind cooking streams oh god keep strong oh let's go boil mash them stick
them in a stew i can show you my washing board and my cutting board well i totally didn't buy a
cutting board that literally says boil mash them stick them in a stew well i have a hobbit cut well
lord of the ring cutting board again chopping board or cutting board and then no more refling
are we one more refling shy oh no one refling just dropped out but yes i'm very interested for
this prop to arrive my reflings are perishing the candy keep up with me the cat oh i thought we're
doing teams we are uh is there like four like this i think i did it right
in germany it's hard to find a good steakhouse that refling had the ground in the loading screen
and it went splat on his squads it's four is it this is eight winner loses a four okay okay okay
is there not one more refling uh one squad's gonna be three maybe it'll give me three because i'm
the horse i don't want to cheat sit at all okay whoa you came in just in tech maybe
you're a cute old fish you stop that you're gonna make me blush you're gonna make me ink
being so nice like that tundra run complete levels to increase your crown rank
huh who's my squad oh why are you wait why am i separated from my squad
i'm separated from them okay okay wait hold on out sorry i've not played this one out
excuse me pardon me coming through okay okay progress okay i'm actually just kind of getting
swept by the crowd i'm gonna be honest the fruit doesn't stand a chance against me i'm being propped
up by all these reflings are you squidding me right now oh probably legend thank you for the tip
okay i'm just i'm just going for it is anyone okay my teammates are ahead thank goodness i'm
literally uh i'm literally dead weight right now i'm an anchor okay okay squad position is third
okay i'm letting the team down i'm letting them down kind of oh maybe oh no we're first oh i'm
helping i'm helping i'm helping my squadron we're four
how the frick is are any of my squad alive or did we all make it through
i think all my squad is through oh no one isn't did one disconnect no
how do i see my squad i don't know thank you brilliant legend for the tip
who's in who's this team i don't know i don't have enough time to process
oh we qualified though that's the good news oh there's my team there asterix duster fantasy and
sad surprise are my team okay we did it we did it i'm totally not dead weight when quick i used to
be a jellybean like you and then it took a stunning to the knee oh yeah we sick we flin maybe sticky
pretty sure my squad just saved me you have like markers on your squad's head
yeah oh no it's the reino game i'm gonna cause everyone to lose i'm sorry teammates carry me the best you
can stomp and grind what a cute reino reino girl confirmed okay no more okay that thing freaking
went for me stop wait i'm just standing here i'm actually just standing here so wait you want me
to go on your back no no i know the other way around let me on your okay i'm safe my teammate is
literally carrying me and we can do it we can do it but if we both get pushed off the map we're in
so much trouble we are in so much trouble what about uh dempo's ice toy becomes material for gen 2
well i've got a fun stream coming off actually i'm gonna draw your gen 2 suggestions um it's not
next week but the week after i'm gonna draw gen 2 suggestions um so you guys are allowed to suggest
what you want yes if you suggest slime i'll actually draw it um but it's how i would want them to look
again it's oh no it's pain no literally oh no oh dear we didn't make it but that's okay that was fun
playing as a team because i didn't have to do anything i didn't have to do anything but yes
you're allowed to suggest what you want me to draw is ms pain before anyone's like oh my god mlg
i'm gonna see if marcie's willing to give me the bases she made for the alternative designs that
she drew of us so you guys can be like i won a lollipop slime and then i'll just copy and paste
the body and then i'll like draw my little bit on top i'm sorry i made us lose no it was fun
i want to do more squads i'm here for the squadron oh what team have we got now
we have five teams
all based on marcie's body no no no no um marcie has bases from when she drew all if you didn't
see the stream marcie actually drew all designs of us which was really fun um and uh i was just
gonna ask her like oh can i pinch them for my we stream idea because i don't actually draw i
shocker i don't actually draw um and holy crap you guys were like sliding and going for it
it's over i failed you know we're gonna play again don't be silly the design she made for
you was so cute the rifling slippers oh my gosh i so badly want them to be a thing because they're
just absolutely lovely she spectated me
oh yeah those bases were just marcie's base except for a zero
was it no our team went first turn rhino to last on that one also the zeros design yeah do you
like this straight up milk kind of sweater look to a zero i'm inclined to agree i like the um
chanel look that marcie drove uh chibi as well stroney is what i am always watching you first
match sorry rifling buddies it's okay you can do it you're allowed to you don't have to be mlg pro
all the time don't don't be a silly sausage and put that kind of thing on you oh wait you've got
assassins creative i see you where are you where are you i saw it's you i swear i saw it's you
am i going crazy i knew i saw it's zero zero proof we can't be playing that hat was fabulous
you can step on us this slippers thank you for doing the story first time playing this game but
you're enjoying it i'm glad it's just like a silly game it's got such upbeat music as well
like it's so fun and goofy and and it's like even if you get knocked off you're not like mad at
yourself you're just like ah you know oh good everything is guaranteed to win there will be
four winners this round oh dear there's one team that hasn't scored anything yet oh dear
it's not looking good my it's not looking good
i wish it gave assigned like team names so i could be like oh this team whoever's in this
team oh we're humping each other oh no do worse players behind are you the only one on the map
no you're not zero oh okay there we go i'm sorry team no no no no it's not like that it's goofy game
three squads qualified oh wait there's an odd number of you never mind we won
at the end will you take in consideration the scottish is more you mean make more scottish
is more i can do that i don't think there are many games that make me sweat more than this one
i felt that oh i almost choked there don't worry i did the choking around these parts
yeah team names and team member names would be nice yeah even so i can just be like oh the
avocado team or something as simple as that uh what
what
are you guys getting points oh
i would not have gotten that i'm not even kidding
oh my brain does not work like that there's no way i would have gotten anywhere near points in this
i mean you could browse those spectators and name them yourself i don't know who's the part of
whose team though which is why it'd be impossible to give you his name gotta remember which tells
of the fruit you should play mario car it's a 12 game uh i suck at mario car um the new versions
of mario car i can't play but if you want to roll me in the game absolutely i'm more than
happy to play mario car but there's no way in heck i'm winning i don't know how it works
i was cheating last time and i was oh i was getting used to hold back um
um just so i can win oh there you go two squads we're in the last squadron
what's it gonna be
hexagon i've not got a switch we still qualify let's go
oh what refling team will be stan left standing is the question and none other than the most
recognizable game hexagon oh it's funny how they don't face you to each other
now we do have to work as a team without sabotage on the board too much because you have friends
so you can't just be going all willy nilly or else you're gonna perish
day worst player might be in for a good player reward i don't know what i was trying to say
there let's try so you might be thinking squady is taking a very interesting tactic and destroying
a layer that the others have yet to reach
hmm seems like we're quite populated up here there's a lot of reeflings on the yellow we're
starting to fall down though you'll never guess what the hexagons are almost gone
oh okay okay okay look i'm not a commentator i'm just doing my thing
so they're killing each other friends this weakness leaving the body what are you
are you perishing your teammates you're not supposed to hurt your teammates
friends what friends just a miserable little pile of secrets those wengas oh i don't know that
reference now there are three reeflings who are already on the lowest layer
hmm
lay wink is trying to take out tiny spiny me so i don't think they're actually
wait did they just take themselves out i think they just took themselves out
solid blake is the only survivor of his team cookie fumbler and tiny spiny might actually
take themselves out they are a part of the same take same team as nonism sorry i get so intense um
cookie fumbler is just absolutely going through the hexagons not really maximizing his time with them
the winners are the worst player solid blake parallaxian and lewain congrats on the winners
i failed
wow the lobby code six delta vector five bravo master chief the go clearly
someone's got some errors in this game and it's none of us it's one of you but it's none of us
okay solid clutch if you want a streamable cart game you may look at disney's speed storm i
haven't played it since the beta but it was actually pretty fun gg i lost in the first
round but that was fun award yeah well you can go again big fans race to the finish line oh yeah
yeah okay squad height who's our squad who's my squad i see why am i so far away from my own
squad i was dinky okay i need to focus i need to do good for my squad mates i can't let them down
it's i'm literally on it as i'm saying i must focus i can't let my two mates down
i'm on my anime arc where they're like super intense for like no reason
and they're like oh i must do this i must do this this isn't about me this is about my my team
mates oh i'm tired i'm weary i'm hungry but no i must persevere because that's what they would do
for me so please allow my focus to come to me damn wait let's try that again let's try that again
hold on a minute hold on a minute let me recover let me recover okay let me is that a good idea to
go on that or a bad idea to go on that oh yes me us we flin both of us just went flying there
oh maybe it's better to do this i don't know and maybe whoa and it may be
stop august the wind just stole me i'm coming i'm doing it team mates please wait for me
oh give me another chance give me another chance hold on give me another chance
what are they doing in the chain what the heck i didn't even know you could do that
please please
um i tried i tried i did what i could we're 13th we're fourth sorry three place did we win
are we in qualified
wow oh sorry i told the teams i didn't make it there's asterix renji and duster fantasy are
my teammates i sucked at this you're left look i'm so tilted oh no
haha stroney saved the farm yes if i win we do the farm but first the milking chamber
yours will be all pent up for the flight coming over to get to the farm so that's the first order
of business okay gate crash we can do this come on let's go two minutes let's go i was the first
and i just tell it everything and lost oh no wow oopsies
wow
oh i bumped over that actually went surprisingly well
we got trolled by that door it wasn't opening
oh i got trolled okay hold up wait oh okay okay it's fine we're doing it can i get a boost
close enough
i'm sending in this one okay i made it i made it six points
oh careful you can do it go asterix go teammate go go teammate go send it
yours level over i think we did it
hello hi hi thanks for joining we're playing team uh full guys so i'm written for my teammates
and myself uh having to win
gg sorry to you no no it's okay it's all fun and games yes yes fun and game
reflings make that woman ink sorry i don't know that was an internal though i was supposed to
yes it's my favorite one reflings on your mark get set
send it
we can do it we can do it let's go
oh my god me and this refling are on the same wavelength let's go
oh jump refling jump speed boost
let's go i love this one so much i hope they make more wow i've got speed boost coming up
oh can i hit it can i hit it come on come on come on three three three
is there a fourth no no no there's not fourth but that's okay
let's go oh i love that one so much oh no where are you going are you going the wrong way
are you going the wrong way by accident yeah you're gonna yeah go that way
oh no but it's okay oh we qualified anyway let's go
have to go bye bye thanks for hanging don't worry if you have to go
if we make you ink now do we get red ink i should never have told you it's the ketchup season
you're done for mods and i'll eat that man i suck at that one oh it's so fun though
even as a non-finisher give me a second don't worry we know it it no
no i was someone sent me a marshmallow that i forgot to answer hold on i'll check marshmallow
when stream is perishing i really want an artwork of stroney with a refling in her lap
sliding down together in this game i don't i'll commission it because i'm already going to
commission the elden ring when we get we finish it right i can do this i'm a brave little cuttlefish
and i can jump on the lily pads i'm a water i'm a water beater anyway so i should be able
owie my bum i think someone landed on my head okay it's fine though i can do it i can do it i can
do it if i really oh no sugar i think this is what i'm always getting stuck at okay it's fine
did they change this i remember struggling so badly on this
okay we did it we did it it's fine
oh my gosh oh no oh wait why is this different
no what is the difference
oh no what does it mean i don't know the pattern okay no no no i can't do this i'm messing up
from a team i can't do it that way i need to go this way sorry sorry team i just suck in general
okay hold on hold on hold on okay okay i'm here i'm here i'm here i'm doing it
okay i helped a little bit i guess
get titted i thought that comment was gonna go somewhere else
um
i did oh no oh oh uh oh spaghetti oh we didn't make it but that's okay that was so fun
they need to give me oh no it was us who were eliminated that's so embarrassing
eeps are bad okay we tried our best okay that's all that matters
wow
you can always suck at starting you did good i think i did all right what's this one power
trip oh i don't recognize this one you guys are gonna have to show me what it is what it is what's up
power trip grab batteries and color tiles to win is this splatoon be honest i'm pretty sure
splatoon is put your anchor route oh we should definitely play splatoon yeah can i like can you
guys stream sniping splatoon oh my gosh this game is so cute oh i love it
oh he's trying to chase after but he can't oh he grabbed them
i'm brainy going for it he's just correcting all the blues doesn't get grabbed
lord of storms you need to pick up a battery in order to change the map find someone find
a yellow team member with a battery there you go you got the hang of it you got the hang of it
stream sniping and splatoon is not as possible but not easy would i have to
and you will get that victory royale literally the only time i can win is if i have three other
reeflands helping me sell them ring all over again um you can make lobbies and splatoon okay uh we
might give it a shot then i've never played it but i do comprehend that i'm to color the grounds
oh blue team is winning by far 200
although it could be lost just as quickly as it's gained it really can
oh we're fighting over it we're doing a little we're doing a little salsa dance over in this corner
oh we're already finished well
well okay okay are you in recommends splatoon for stream sniping oh oops
uh you can also do golf with friends can you stream snake golf with friends
that one bean that looks like a reefland jelly bean
any jelly
i don't need splatoon to cover everything with ink honestly you can lobby golf with friends
golf with friends goes to a hundred stop we need to play that i didn't even know that
i'm pretty sure i have it
um well it's just to v2
furious and notorious not to be confused with each other are both taking the lead oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't mean to do that i didn't mean to jinx it like that please forgive
oh okay well you know why you're not doing that bad
any jelly yeah oh i never finished my sense
veiler golf collab with friends uh actually i might set that up i'm interested in
i've contacted someone from pixel link and she was super nice i'm just waiting to see if she
wants to add me or not because like i gave her my discord
i'm well obviously she's busy and it's been a few days oh we've got our winners wait
huh wasn't it was a tie
oh
okay i'm gonna gonna have a fun rest of juggling game thank you
for joining and thank you for getting stuff done that you need to get done okay because
i know today's a work day because i'm dumb and i thought it was a weekend for everyone for some
reason it was supposed to be final round and i picked the wrong map i'm wondering if because
the last one it shoved like two big teams together oh there's one okay uh i can't tell who's on whose
team yeah until someone actually falls off the map hexagon the natural final map honestly
i think it is a really good thing though
there's still a few okay outwings going for the i'm trashing this hexagon good luck everybody else
method oh he's going for it oh my god he's poking a hole in it like a jack o lantern get it because
the tiles are orange oh okay he gets a taste of his own medicine unfortunately
i believe in chair someone says lord of storms just taking it nice and easy on the purple
actually going around the circumference he is joined by kerby mobile unknown if friendly or
oh um kerby doesn't like their odds though okay lord of storm is taking the middle
oh someone just dropped straight down to the yellow notorious unbelievably was still on the
blue hexagons above i'm refusing to go down truly refusing to go down
okay we are on the yellow we all are sharing the yellow there's a few gaps in the blue below but
hardly anything i'm good i'm good bless you that wasn't a sneeze i almost threw up
well that wasn't a sneeze i almost threw up because my throat was dry
i'm gonna need a humidifier for my a throat remember oh we have our winners sink outwings
furious and kerby mobile congrats on our winners yep i got grabbed did they steal you
even your model has the cat about to puke me like no
starting hacking up i don't know why if my throat gets dry my body's like oh it's time to throw up
and it's like no my throat is dry relax please i'm begging you i'm begging you
okay oh no wait yeah oh no wait i only got i said 40 is someone's got bad connection
are you squidding me right now ah humidifier fun going live really legend thank you for the five
i don't need any money i can buy it i promise literally i just bought a dog shot collar for
streams and i bought this really cool prop i cannot wait to show you the prop for the ASMR
stream everyone's gonna be like what the f are you doing oh let's go let's nail it reeflings i don't
know who's on my squadron just yet but let's go three two one go go go go
okay oh oh i hit him with a oh hit him with a
oh yeah i know i got bumped but it's okay jump oh yeah
i don't see any of my teammates you're all enemies oh my god you're the vtuber that isn't
her countdown right now uh you're the freaking beach oh wait no i'm thinking of the other
vtuber hold on wait oh no oh no oopsies can i do it can i be first can i be first
someone went in front of me who was it we're first place
hmm
level over yeah i saw that about kizuna AI
mods in gondak um yeah i thought yeah something happened to the channel
false and wrong get super chad get super chad get super chad she's so cute when she's excited
i just think it's the best map literally i get to slip and slide on my belly that's so fun
stroney's wildly good at that one that's probably why i like it so much like oh i can actually win
the worthy gig uh the worthy gig is when you put your uh is what you put your clothes on
to dry outside and it spins in a circle with the wind the game cheated and knocked me off
map okay it keeps putting me in the same team danny i'll restart the lobby because it's putting me
in the same team and i want a chance for like everyone to try and have a chance to be in the same team
i was not paying attention for that to happen
oh my god i think i'm about to throw up oh no it was a burp it was a burp it's fine
out out stop it out stop it right let's recalibrate
okay wow we made it there is a teammate that's ahead thank goodness
because i am i am not doing so good
oh surely i can make it okay okay we made it we've got a checkpoint okay look okay okay okay
oh okay i'll take it i'll take it no it was a speed boost it was a positive okay it's a positive
okay let's
okay it's fine i did oh i don't want to win any i don't want to be first place you
know i have to give the other reeflings a chance you know like i just i gotta give the reeflings
a chance sorry my controller about to suck and get open in the settings menu don't worry
throwing up on stream would definitely be a first hey mommy got warmed i got walloped honestly
wow did we make it oh no we didn't make it but that's okay right i'll reset the next lobby
because i don't think it's swapping the teams unless it is swapping the teams and
i'm just getting really weird luck is it swapping the teams for you guys yes or no
yes or no no it's not swapping it's not swapping okay okay i reset the lobby after this one
and we'll get a new lobby code it isn't i'm in the same team as last okay okay i am learning
doordish avoid the fake doors can the reeflings avoid the fake doors is the question will we
spectate it's you oh okay we've got some leader reeflings all the way at the front
somehow you're ahead of everyone oh well i jinxed it i'm sorry i jinxed it i'm so sorry
hey we got it we got it oh it's a one in five four in five three in five
does it just get less and less this one's so good for you to watch everyone just
head button doors
okay i like this one
oh let's see what teams get there oh level over these perv reeflings in slow motion didn't
make it have some studying to do for a test good luck on your test gambati do your best
and something something if you chew gum whilst you study and then chew gum during the test your
brain will connect the two doors i don't know if that's true or not but yeah that one is the
ultimate rng but yeah like i like when it's up to chance and not skill
my squad is on it let's go this one is it is avoid the thick doors can't avoid mommy's
thick doors i don't think i've ever had my butt cheeks described as a thick door before
oh yeah you want to open this door open them oh it's the fruit one careful
okay you're gonna make oh god this one kind of makes me a bit motion sick
you're simply gambling addictive look all i'm gonna say is that belcher was really fun
but if you get sucky runs it sucks the soul out of you but as soon as you get a good run
you get all the endorphins i don't think i can spectate i'm not being funny that's like
legit giving me illness i'm like focusing on chatting said i threw so hard oh don't worry
it's just funny games thank you for playing we're gonna reset the lobby so we get different teams
maybe not a door but like a giant gate castle castle gale shawnee got them elden ring doors
she's stop i know exactly what animation you're referring to when you open up like a door to
something mommy i am seeing starfish is are you getting motion sick too
man i wasn't paying attention i got eliminated oh sorry don't worry we still have time for
more more more i'm actually really enjoying the squads i'm sorry i'm a sick for it i like being
like oh i've got my wee team and i don't have to rely on myself fully when you get sucky runs
it sucks so hard but when you win it's all then okay so gambler right okay yeah gambler
do any of the teams sentence ought to be balanced no we're gonna have to reset the lobby because
it's not like shawkin is about i've been able to get passed around since we did teams i suck
oh you're too sweet strutting what do you mean we're just playing video or am i being dumb
i like squads because i like the feeling of carrying yeah that's why i like being carried
that's why i like squads oh my god we're a match made in heaven rieflin
mommy you made like the first descent as a game wow i've never heard of it
okay now i can actually watch the gameplay because i was gonna be violently ill oh it's
rainos again stomping grand need to be passed around we stand as soon as i get eliminated
chair is still in the run uh we're still got there's still three teams left
oh my god
how do we not spectate recon reform we don't spectate you much do we
no pressure the whole the stream's watching you recon reefling no pressure at all smile
oh first descent is a free third person futuristic sure you want me to want to show
are you gonna see my aimball sure just being very supportive even when you're eliminated
it's so sweet i just i just think it's fun getting to play with all the reeflings
i i like stream sniping i don't have any problem with that i think it's fun like um i wanted to
play apex but apparently people hate apex and i'm like oh it's a shame because like i get to
talk to you in voice chat but i don't know if that puts people off so i just play safe i hope
i hope you play ultra kill i'm pretty sure um azura is playing ultra kill at the moment
i have no idea what the game is about oh two squads left and one that only has three members
my squad through
i'd watch apex couldn't pay me to play it not even if i was on your team we can go into salt
lake city servers because no one plays on that and then it's just us everybody's watching
did a scarier i got knocked out a few rounds ago time for me to choke
look why why did it why does it all grip you in a team and like put you together
are you squidding me right now um anon
strongy is legit slim thick a small figure with sexy hips and cheeks to clap
thank you kindly anon don't mind if i do get my ego stroked what's going on here
stroking my ego while you stroke here so i'm on to you anon thank you
you have 70 days on apex uh carry me question mark i was gonna do drunk apex but i'm not
allowed to go offline until we win and you guys would have to carry me to win that's the only
problem uh but then i was like oh people don't like apex i don't know if people are gonna be weird
about it but like a valorant has teams of five so i could have four reflands with me overwatch
two has four reflands with me apex i can only have two reflands with me wait when you're gonna
play cod with the girls yay yeah when the uh i don't know what cod it was i think cod is a black
up six is coming out or something i was gonna play it with the girl the gorals so just the never
ending stream um destiny two rates sadly i've never played destiny i don't know what it's about i'm not
very good uh but you'd have a full lobby of reflings and apex yes it would be a private lobby on apex
and you would all join the code and then god this game is not getting easier
i talk about a skirt in the rim holy crap wow
oh this is they need a zoom out option held out verse two has a friend system that works well
from playing with refunds unless it breaks i'd give hell divers to a shot apparently it's player
base is dead though after the sony shenanigans congrats ruin desolation zero fu and sassafras
congrats you did it you did it i didn't even know black out four or five worth near did i
all right okay i'm gonna end the lobby because we're gonna start a new one i've forgotten how
to start a new one host a lobby please yes and then show the new code
um vector xylophone vector xylophone mango i'm sorry vector x-ray vector x-ray
meh i don't know what meh is didn't hell divers lose 19 percent of his pc players if you refund
a game on steam you can't buy it so the player that refunded that forced on it sony uh back out of
the plan kind of company make oh that's what it's called make okay congrats if you names make by the
way have you played gears of war i have but not multiplayer i played the campaign many a year ago
now vector the crocodile let's go best detective in the universe wait is that a tv show or something
and did i accidentally say all right waiting for players to join no everyone's here start okay 40
we've got the perfect 40 let's see what we're working with hydration check little reeflings
oh vector from sonic heroes oh we're gonna play that how did you guys know we're gonna play team
chaos because i a chaotic because i've never played them the old xbox 360 gears of war pvp
was very sway oh god oh no can wait we have eight members i have big team okay big team don't mess up
okay big team don't mess up focus focus not that it's making me motion sick oh someone just
perished oh no oh no no no no no i'm sorry team please please team please clutch up please
clutch up team you can do it yeah back up but i believe in you who's my other teammates chili
bogs i believe in you broly legend i believe in you who else do i believe in hold on i need to find
them notorious i believe in you chad gay what name i believe in you is that everyone i believe in
in did i actually skip someone okay i think that's everyone i believe in
did you try the new elton ring dlc i did but we're gonna have to visit it once my dad goes away again
and because i have like insane back-to-back endurance streams planned basically i think like
eight hour back-to-back to back some 12 hours of i'm feeling cheeky she lasted 30 second seconds
she has that hair trick mommy so attached was that she prefers to see the gameplay with us instead
of playing oh no reeflings we never made it oh no oops oops we tried congrats to the reeflings
i made it though congrats oopsies oopsie whoopsies i didn't mean to perish
gg lol i know gg she believed in the only reeflings and didn't make it no no not like that
oh i've not played this one frantic factory beans love to dress up unlock items and express yourself
press the lift buttons to score points i don't know what that means but i will
watch you guys with great intent being eliminated in the first two rounds since
went in the first squad game rip
okay
what
i don't understand what on earth is going on to be honest
so those are
oh
oh once the light goes on you only get a point if you stop down on the light that's on okay okay
okay okay once the light is lit up then you jump on it by the pope when do you plan on using the
shock collar also i'd like to make a bet that you start whimpering in a cute way when you feel the
shock we might help you discover a new fetish hang on steady on and the shock collar is planned
two weeks the actual shock collar stream i'm to use on and
and if it goes well i mean i can use it in general like see we play elton ring and then like we die
when we go against a boss i can shock myself like that now i'm thinking of this damn whoever said that
thank you anon for the tip um i would say it's probably two weeks away i just ordered it
um it's coming from america y'all hello america um so i think it'll take a few days to get here
in roughly two weeks and me you just press buttons yeah when the buttons lit up though
it was me who said that you're welcome
terrible terrible influence on one another wow we can't get away from stomping ground i'm ready
to delete it and put it in the bin rhinos rhinos rhino skirt
literally we can't get away from these rhinos is it that common of a map or are we just getting unlucky
okay how many teams it looks like four teams yeah four teams left get luck replaying have a go each
other oh one's already off the map sorry a little reflinger who we don't speak to you
we're not speaking to you no pressure chad no pressure everyone's watching you
are you a moan can you a moan in this game oh my god your t-pose and you can't a moan in this game
what
how do you do halloween pc um no idea
i got disconnected don't y'all i don't know if oh everyone's spamming hello now
what's going on here
the rhinos were constantly invoking you
strony have you completed elton ring the base game i have once before
with the help of many but i did do it that's the main thing i did do it even though i had
help i did do it so i have played the game i haven't finished the dlc though um i don't
even know how little or far we're into the dlc uh last thing i remember was we found this flower
place and there was a guy on a horse and we beat him up and then there's another guy on the horse
and beat him up as well but we had to whack him a few times oh you're playing volleyball
oh where's the ball oh come on replays you can do it there is one point scored already
uh if i recall you're about halfway yeah we defeated the lion
horse man in flower place is optional
um we did try and get the guy that turns into a snake but he got the best of us so
um i think we're just kind of exploring i don't know if we'll go back to base game
or not i'm unsure but someone gave me a special crossbow that goes
uh so i'm helping to get the the enemy a little bit in Elden Ring i'm going
oh that volleyball does not want to go down
wow
i remember only you laughing so much while some reefling was trying to kill it did with
the big sword but this should be like every moment of the stream so it's just so sorry
i was laughing at a reefling
wait this snake guy picking up a reefling was i laughing and nervousness because he was getting
rolled to complete weapon upgrades the base game would be helpful yeah i think i need to do that
problem oh no you did everything right i think you did everything right anyway
mommy getting the enemy to bleed with the full auto crossbow what a fumble honestly the game's so like
it's even
how have you brought him
how did you bring that back oh congrats to the winners h uh jk heather sasa france
blank ellies and social Blake Blake Blake let's go that was a good comeback i thought you if
that was ogre holy clutch literally right i think we need to reset the lobby every time now i'm so
sorry but it's to make sure that we get different teams every time the comeback and then the win
point the code is Romeo whiskey
uh kilo yankee foxtrot that took me a second there but i got there i was like if i don't panic
i'll be able to do it oh i need to select the game mode sorry i would like to select squadrons
please thank you the comeback and the win do we reset the lobby yes we're gonna shuffle the lobby
every time uh romeo whiskey kilo yankee foxtrot call that sprill
oh uh thank you again to people that have been like clipping funny moments there's a really funny
one that i'm getting edited soon tm that i'm excited about i also put a clip on twitter
that isn't out yet because i don't know if i can upload it or not it's okay i gotta go now and go
eat enjoy your food either takimasu have fun we will have fun thank you for your kind words
why not rotate between squads and something else what but if i do anything else i'm not in your
squad i can do jewels if you want it to be if you want it to be really intimate reeflings
i can do jewels is that what you want the chance to be with just mommy and your team
me just me and you you have to carry oh maybe we should do that if we do jewels everyone has
to jump on their jewels back and then we go wait this is the first one
um am i gonna win i think i'm gonna be eliminated again i'm so sorry to the reeflings of my team
being intimate one lucky reefling good luck okay okay let's let's do it
let's qualify to score points where the heck am i going
uh what
oh i'm getting a bit confused with the science to this someone needs to clip you saying give me
your butterfly no that makes no sense of context but i literally clean it i get a wings gate whoa
whoa i don't have that kind of reaction time
oh i did this time but what no reeflings no don't hit no reeflings don't hit the button
no reeflings stop reeflings you're trolling me okay let me make it oh did i just kill that reefling
oh wait is this the way are we to go down oh my god we're to go down in the middle go down in
the middle reeflings don't get caught up don't get caught up don't get caught up i can do it i can
do it i can do it it's right there i can do it jump i can do it okay i did it now what
what is this
oh my god i can do it i can do it for my team this is for you team oh i did it
oh my god what is this map it's nightmare it is if you don't know where you're going it's so confusing
it's over for me yeah you want the chance of jewels okay how about we do jewels next
and then but we're not allowed to go we have to jump on our jewels back like all of us
i was behind you the whole time yeah did we win
no oh no reeflings we're so unlucky oh and that just that show of the upside down reefling
falling off the map oh we're so unlucky we're trying our best though
mm finally made it through the first round damn after land
thank you for the tip anonymous someone needs to clip you saying give me your
blue give it when training right now starts right now i have a collection of six i have plenty to
go around although i might be adding to the collection soon i saw i saw a very unique
animation and now i want something whoa wait why are you standing in the corner
what is this what do you do
is your goal to finish the keypad together
oh wow no way you guys are smart enough to do that how do you know
no way that's so smart sorry that's actually so smart
oh we're making a few mistakes so we're getting there
whoa oh my god i love this i want to play this one i'm going to ask the question every
reefling wants to know but is too afraid to ask does strongly like a reeflings ink salty or sweet
i like it anyway it comes thank you i don't for the tip if it comes from a reefling
i'll take it doesn't matter the quality the condition
if it's reefling ink i want it do you understand i want it
why are you doing it reeflings look at the monitor to know what you need to make
it's so funny to see the lag because like one reefling would be like i'm helping
and then it's like destroying it
mommy has an ink tax oh the only kind of tax i'll accept
this is strong and you've got to be saying stuff like that when i'm helping my team
oh maybe i should do that next time so we can win
my teammates are not allowed to leave the mute stream for two minutes and then i just say the
most absolute veil things i want to do to you
oh reefling are you still sleeping oh you just stay asleep mommy just needs to help herself okay
oh it's the christmas map
that's so evil but effective well i mean my team isn't up anymore so oh we got a little love heart
hello hello let's do it let's do it let's do it
man this is unfair i like it did the room just get 10 degrees warmer
go reeflings go go reeflings go go reeflings go you can do it
okay maybe don't do that that was dangerous you do you're doing again you're doing again
that's so dangerous little reefling
oh god a tent got made you're welcome
oh wait i don't know i don't know if french means cringe or not
but to say you're welcome in french you say yapat qua
stronti's secret cheat me locating the blood of the reeflings to the lore huh
i'm wondering should i just do that mommy will there be a drinking game with us yes
i've not decided what the drinking game will be
yeah next week we're doing puzzles because it's nice and calm and quiet
but i get to hate the image
and then you guys get to come into the puzzle and then we do the puzzle together
inking cube the blood knows where it just needs to go man
let me just play drunk souls drink whenever you die to a boss
i mean if you want drunk elden ring sure i don't mind whatever game you want to play
is buckshot roulette a puzzle that would be a fun buckshot roulette is going multiplayer so we
could maybe do stream sniping and that if i pray i'm like 100 sure the creator of buckshot roulette
said that there was going to be like public access lobbies for streamers um which would be
insane trying to like figure out what's going on all of us point and be like no you should
uh yourself no you should uh yourself stronti no you'll perish did you just fart am i going crazy
did i just hear a fart in game did i make that up i'm going schizophrenic yeah who do we know
okay noob lord we don't normally spectate you a little egg plant
speaking of farting that's not far that's a loaf of bread hold on a minute there'll be no
fart in here it's latex creaking it's not a two oh okay i didn't know i was could have sworn
i was like why did they randomly put fart dot mp3 in the middle of this oh no wait are you
doing fine okay it's just your connection sorry i can't look too long on this map for some reason
it goes from a motion signal i only get motion sickness in a car though i'm not in a freaking
video game like i've never normally experienced it in a video game but i think because the camera
keeps spinning in a circle we're baking a loaf out here aren't you guys always baking a loaf i
thought guys like pooped multiple times a day aren't you all making loaves right now you have a
morning loaf of bread then you have a night loaf of bread damn i got triple grabbed man reeflings
are feeling a bit randy today clearly if we're all grabbing rubbing instead
not really no i think guys apparently poop multiple times a day that was a real gropey
we are not careful he's usually one loaf of bread a day i made it so far and all the time
how long will today's stream be um i was technically supposed to be wrapped up by now
i'll give a few more rounds okay and then i'll um i'm gonna go get a bath just to try and
feel a bit better i whatever you do reeflings don't be a girl that's all i'm gonna that's all i'm
gonna say okay depends on how much celery we end up having a few more rounds hey yo wait i just got
the joke a few oh you want a few more rounds it depends how much celery you have for me
oh come on it makes sense celery it makes it whiter or something i don't know
it makes the load bigger you're welcome have you ever tried one of those warm bags for the
ketchup season i use the hot water bottle and it takes away the pain but i take painkillers and
all of that like i'm i'm not with no no i'm not with some girls fucking like suffering for some
reason and don't take painkillers and i'm like why it's absolute agony like it's crippling agony
and why would you not take a painkiller i don't understand like whenever i hear like a chick being
like i don't take painkillers when i'm on my ketchup season i'm just like well clearly the
pain's not that bad because oh congrats oh you've got a kill on congrats broly legend curbie mobile
fox hound jesu and pacifer you've got a freaking kill on aw i need the kill they have those
heatable plushies for ketchup season aw right new lobby new lobby new wait what what are the
challenges call the fire play any level in any game wait my challenges are kind of getting counted
though that's cool right yes yes yes go go go right the code this time is three hold on i'm
trying to pick right do you want jewel or do you want squad again that was my first one of our
congrats what is it did you get the endorphin rush you want jewel right okay we'll try jewel
congrats to the one reflin that's in my team we'll try jewels okay your buddy out brieflings
find yourself a buddy i'll take you back to the school days the code is three november zulu kilo
oh julia julia hope i can carry stroney yeah i don't know who's team i'm gonna get right when
do we start don't run you have to jump on your jewels back okay how do you piggyback on pc we'll
figure it out hopefully we don't get like a slime or a timed mission if we start with an odd number
someone really is reliving the old school days oh no remember the teacher would be like oh you can
just buddy up with me and i was like i always got i always got buddied up with the bad kids
because i used to do all the work i think it was just easier for the teacher to be like oh they're
not going to be disruptive if they're with stroney so you heard mommy don't run mommy does the countdown
exactly i'm going to fail someone no no don't put that on your you're going to try your best for
someone you need to turn that thinking around you're not gonna fail anyone all right we're at an
even number so i'm quite happy to start on an even number need an audio where teacher stroney bodies
up with me that'd be the most well and appropriate audio created so far refling team building exercise
okay his on his team 37 players oh no did it not connect it said 38 and before i'm the one that's
solo who's my buddy wait how do i wait wait remember we need to jump on each other's backs so find your
buddy who's mine right broly legends my buddy how do i get on your back no reflings you're to jump on
your buddy's back right i do this press up on the d-pad if you're on your x-bow there we go right
carry me literally yay oh my god look at how cute your own leg we're all on each other's backs this
is so cute oh no wait how do i do it all right my turn my turn oh right okay maybe not oh
wait how about this like this okay let's go more span those three things i'm gonna hand
look how cute we all like jumping on each other's backs oh my god we're all so cute
oh my god weapons if i had an antenna call you'd feel it right now against your back
can y'all feel each other's tentacles on each other's backs it's just a vibration okay it's just a
vibration oh my god look i can't they all are on each other's back i'm gonna explode oh no oh no
we can't regroup it's too dangerous oh no refling god refling oh no i'm on my own
oh no wait who can i go in your back let me on your back put me on your back right now i need
to go i need help across the finish line go go put me on your back okay let's go i need a
refling okay yeah that was it oh no you did it okay okay take me take me take me yeah
i got grabbed uh this is amazing oh no my refling
oh no he's so lost someone patiently oh no
are you not gonna need each other's back oh oh no did we get in are we eliminated oh no
we tried our best when you try our best but you don't succeed
that was so good i'm not like i'm not upset or anything that was so good i got mounted by mommy
i'm so sorry about no that was funny big apologies to my teammate no you tried your
best that's the main thing um it's h to ask for a piggyback on pc okay it's too hard to
carry straw day honestly though okay you don't have to do the piggyback thing you can just go
for it now you can just run go reflings go check this out okay what we're checking you out
what refling was that was it you that said check this out i think oh right well we checked out for
a little bit i thought the piggybacking thing was fun yeah if i'm in the round i'll force you
to piggyback but if i'm not in the round then you don't have to do it either i got sabotaged
i don't know how to make someone else figure i don't know it seems really i like press up on
the d pad and i think the other person has to press up but we can cancel each other out by
accident okay carrying strawnee with those on your back must be both distraction and motivating
honestly i wish the jelly beans could have a little bbl i'd buy that cosmetic i don't care
sure i'd buy the the afo that cosmetic
oh there's only a few eliminations that that was like what six
wow person who pressed it forces the one who gets carried okay we're learning we're learning
if we piggyback you you can whisper in our ears it's okay refling keep going you're doing so good
keep it up faster faster you're almost there keep going and just something bbl oh that was the
question i reflin asked on um on marshmallow they were like you always say your butt is bigger you
got a bbl is it natural i'm like yeah it's natural it's complete luck because i'm small in height
the the fat has to go somewhere and it picked my thighs and butt but i think because i ride a bike
as well it kind of shaped my like where my fat distribution goes and it resulted in like a good
like uh butt hip ratio type thing
are you sweating reflin your breathing is pretty hard right now
short stacked goblin core cuttlefish honestly i'm not being those allegations i'm tiny
um i thought i was normal size to be honest like height wise but apparently not
apparently i'm a teeny weeny are you trying to keep us distracted because you've achieved it
haha some people are born lucky oh i'm not literally it's complete luck like uh it's not like
i'm trying to like build my body to look a certain way or anything like that like no i sit
on my arse all day long i do walks and i ride a bike that's about it
strontius carry size okay i'll take that that's a compliment burning the thigh fat with the leg
workout so but power remained if mummies on her back and it comes to a full finish we'd
win with the extra inches get oh that is so funny stop that's hilarious your little jelly bean
wiener on the full finish strontius just fun sized yeah the ring game always stresses me out
we're watching lily lily lily lily lily lily we've got parallaxation lee wink regi zero
vilt cadmouth brainy
is that a second word supposed to be what i think it is or is my brain just making stuff up out there
oh no here we go one two three four five six seven eight
they've got still got a few jewels left jewels are showing up
like a carton all you hear is a grunt and someone wins
wow sorry teammate no no no you tried your best you don't have to apologize for trying your best
that was terrible i could have not got any worse screw those hips it's a type of horse
strontius sighs and courage is sharing with others because i'm so we they went extinct
oh i didn't know that it just kind of sounds like my you know you know the rest of the goes
oh look at the jewels go survive to score points
wait is someone i just have is someone already are you posing i think i was posing
now who do we not watch is there anyone here we haven't watched
you're my teammate cookie fumbler i don't think we've watched you no pressure cookie fumbler sorry
they were in extinct they were related to zebras
don't worry to make you feel oh i'm sorry i'm sorry cookie don't feel bad is nerfing
yourself and losing on purpose i'm so caring yes on purpose why of course
did we not think we've spectated everyone here yeah then i remember seeing the eggplant
oh your paws all they're like emoting to each other that's so cute oh someone just
perished off the map fit did you just who won
oh there's three jewels remaining wait one four jewels remaining
sorry eggplant refling i let you down no audio attack against people peaceful
reeflings from my meh honestly though he he he
hexagon our classic beloved hexagon right i think i'll do two more jewel
and then we'll redirect into sheepsters
oh four teams only one will remain by the end of this round
oh okay we're smacking ourselves down actually wait i don't think we've ever
oh no wait she'd be saying ASMR roleplay okay sounds good everyone did great today
literally it was fantastic i had so much fun please do not think i'll be shy and not play
this a game again and i do have tons of other multiplayer games though to like either revisit
or try it apparently golf with friends we can do um obviously i'm scottish and if you didn't know
golf was invented in scotland so i'll just roam smoky naturally sorry it's just the way it is
i don't make the rules i don't say it's a it's a perk you know like uh i'm frost resistant uh
i'm golf buff uh what other scottish thing i would say i'm alcohol buffed but i'm
such a lightweight it's terrible to my pirate pair reefling i'm sorry i got disconnected
yeah i'm really looking forward to golf with y'all yeah that would be an interesting one
i wonder if i get like rolled in smoke um we'll just play the default golf maps like i
don't think we need to do like any downloads or anything in skyrim terms you start with a therian
golf exactly wink wink i know what i mean looks like i have to reinstall it yeah is that golf with
friends i think it's golf with friends is the hundred lobby right now that i'm expecting a hundred
reeflings that's a lot of reeflings you know and there's only one hole to putt into uh uh uh
come on that wasn't too bad
oh no way you're all the way up there that's ridiculous
why are you so freaking good are you gonna run out though
i don't know oh
uh it's getting by a bore here oh my god
and i don't know shoni can provide three holes to putt into oh my god congrats black
ailes and sassafras for the jewel
whoa i've never seen this cut scene before was that did you have to purchase that idle games athlete
oh my god that was so good right we'll reset the lobby and we'll do another jewel
i need to do it right though don't forget this fourth secret and not you're done
right jewels the code is delta sierra make yankee golf
that cut scene was great nah i just got carried
sorry sorry shoni i apologize it's not golf with friends it's golf it okay golf it
i'll definitely get the right game is it marbles on stream i don't know if you can do marbles on
stream on youtube i thought it was a twitch only kind of thing i choked at the top don't worry it
happens to the best of us don't worry refling it's okay yes don't worry i'll put it on the schedule
like way before way before delta okay we've got an even number which is good hmm people sass
uh you still answer marbles yeah i can take a look after this if you want i'll play one more game
after this one and then i'll read some marbles and then redirect into sheepsters deal
okay we haven't we have a correct amount i assume no one else is trying to get in
and am i in am i yeah okay we'll play it safe that's an even number
do the marbles apply the same for you as a girl
uh i'm not allowed to like anything i'm not allowed to private reply i never did that in
the first place but i didn't understand what it meant oops um
um strongy emmy has more subs than you know oh thank god
fucking hell i really did not want to be the bloody leads thank god right that's good remember
subscribe to emmy bezu and i did not want to be first place oh no what does this mean
uh uh no no freaking pressure but you need to clutch up chili blogs do you hear me you need to
clutch
you need to clutch up i keep dying like instantly marbles on stream isn't playable on youtube
but you can stream it via obs and use discord or chat bolts for viewer uh
subscribe to all the girls including cb oh no we didn't make it we tried our best though
we couldn't even jump on each other's back this time clutcher can't get us a bit dramatic
me a calipha
calipha
sorry team it's juice
whoa i wonder if i'm eliminated oh i'm so surprised
mama mia i never saw orange that round god i'm getting rolled in this game so badly
clipped by the propeller i'm sorry team it got pushed off the platform i don't know how we qualified
we both died oh stop did you actually i'm getting so unlucky i just suck classic classic gamer girl
can't beat stereotype yeah yeah yeah one v one me on black ops then we'll see what a stereotype
i look like then you give me a wee bit warm up i'm off on one
wow
it froze on load and i saw my body flying away when it caught up
well we hope that you suck i want to find out
the good thing about leads in these jellybean games we get to hang out and chat with mommy
well actually it's just turning into a zazoo because i keep perishing i'm like oh should i
bring up marshmallows on the other screen at this rate hold on i think i probably could
you won't hear any game music but that's because of me hold on i'm opening up
marshmallows so i can read them whilst i suck at this game but you swallow that's
something oh actually while i'm at it i'll make sure i'm redirected into sheepster's success
the blue the redirect on youtube has uh connected successfully and how do i do it
oh right marshmallow why does the audio stop when i'm not in the thing
wow okay hold on right in game again oh no they'll look over in the peripheral and spline in the air
ishmar and stream for real sorry i was just a fucking new thing okay he made it he made it
hi strawnee uh i had a thought and i'd like to extend an idea i don't know how much
you motherfucking know
i don't know how much you're gonna be h word when your dad's brother so i propose that you
do a daily pantalon's color update oh because i'm actually gonna be wearing clothes okay right
you revived that at the end because i was like where the f are you going with that riplin okay
you revived that at the end i kind of get what you mean my teammate is carrying me it's hard to
strawnee wants to be carried yeah okay what i just want to watch you play all the saddest games
and watch all the saddest movies and just hold just to cry your eyes out and tell you it's all
gonna be okay because you're so damn cute when you cry my little my little cry my my sweet little
cry baby seaweed i'm freaking like i'm a wee greeter okay i don't know how like you can't
he get into a movie or like a game or whatever like i'm so in it like i i'm i'm the main character
i'm dealing with everything you know i'm a seaweed now
oh my god i don't even know if i can read this one out loud reflin
how would you feel about being leashed up armorless in the house and walked around like a dog
before i destroy you reflin you are pent up if you pee on the car felt spank your butt raw
reflin you need are you okay it's like firstly in the morning oh no you sent them five hours ago
okay i took that back yeah damn that marshmallow was from john wick streams i'd probably
other than again i cried in the freaking cat game as well
i freaking cried at the industry i'm just warning anyone who didn't get time to watch the
board for straight yes i cry in it like a cry baby and i was looking over my clips for the feet
and uh someone used clips when i was singing those songs with the musician guy like making up songs
what was that even on i just started like coming out with random words none of them even freaking
rained she's a cute cry baby cuttlefish cuddles honestly that alliteration gift though
should do crying ASMR and it's just me remembering all the sad films and stuff i've watched
shawnee's got enough to make a cry compilation already honestly i'll someone clipped when i was
crying over john wick and i just go like but you told me there was a five and my voice is like very
clearly shaking uh hexa rain ring around the rosies that was so hard to cry
shut up i love the song they're so good are you interested in doing a cover of ed sheeran's
i see fire from the hobbit with madame sheebie you mean ed sheeran the like really like insanely
trained and talented singer and you want me to copy one of his songs with his insane voice
i have terrible news i have no way in heck i can come anywhere near to what he's saying
and if she really wants to do song covers i'm so down for her to do stuff though
oh
god i forget how amazing the song is like in these games
all right who we got we've got ferocious noob lord chair tech ninja scrumptious knight
milk cadmium these are are you are you trying to get a piggyback in the middle of this are you
crazy have we spectated chairs chairs won but have we specated them though
sheebie actually suggested it last night oh she's she's in for a fright when she hears her
broken my vocal chords are it's a shame i wish i could but
because mods have a gun to chat said if they spoil that's why well like because yours are all
like oh there's a fifth one there's a fifth one
i was super excited every time you found a track for the android to hear a new song
aw some of them were impossible to sing to i think that there was one that was over in
20 seconds i couldn't even get the rhythm before any words came out my mouth it's fine it's your
job to make us all sing for you oh yeah that kind of singing that what you won you did it
who are those cookie fumbler and wait chair again what the fuck how do you keep winning
clap clap how do you are you like a tryhard or are you new because you don't even have a skin
you don't even have a skin do you even play this game
good job gg he sweated so before okay last one last jewel the code is 5576 you
how are you doing that chair traded his cosmetics for more skill clearly he was like i don't need a
skin i want to surprise you all with my skills in relation to twitter or x are you sure it's
okay to ping us multiple times if you don't see anything yes i never freaking saw this art oh my
god um i got tinfoil artwork of me like next to a board like uh pointing at all these things and
connections um and i never saw it and it was posted like eight years ago the pressure was
getting to me i'm not gonna lie did you see that emi has more subscribers than you know good thank
fucking god she must have jumped up did something get trending on her channel hold on let me check
because oh thank god though i'm so happy i didn't want to be i didn't want to be the leader
unironically name no it says just that oh she has let's fucking go oh that's fantastic let's fucking go
that's so good sorry legit celebrate now about a christmas fucking miracle oh and
her ASMR just came out that's really cute as well oh thank god check what she said on twitter i
don't have access are you squiddling me right now something's trending but not on youtube
is it on her alt twitter hold on twitter is it emi bezu or is it the other one me
uh is it her alt it's probably her alt right yeah it's gonna be her alt
considering it's just her short something thank you for the tip brulee legend yeah alt
where emi did a slaying girl ASMR it literally just came out right is there another refling i
don't want to go in odd on a joe's i might have to change it to four because i don't want any
refling going in on their own is there any other refling trying to get in i know what i'm listening
to after this if emi gets tanky before she goes home she's getting she's doing the dempa ice lolly
thing she has a warning though i hope what she means on twitter oh no is there is there not another
refling i don't want to right i think we'll do quads again because i don't want a refling to be on
their own that's not nice we'll do squadron okay okay i took her audio okay that's fine
uh oh no wait everything just dropped out
okay i don't know if that was a dc i hope that was on purpose don't worry we will play this game
again so don't think we're not gonna do it oh my god i'm so bad that someone's fucking overtook
me a sense i know it probably sounds so weird to be like i mean i'm sure in the average agency
like anyone else would be pissed if they weren't like the leader whatever but like i'm glad i'm not
the lead i don't want to be the lead and like i'd rather have the girls you know i'm being successful
wait how have i got more than i'm confused how have i got more than one jewel did i not change
it to jewels i can't jump on anyone's back right now
it's too dangerous refling
i can do it i can do it i'm actually pretty far ahead hold on
okay okay we can actually do this
okay that's fine that's fine i'm a little it's just allowed to do that
oh my god oh my god wait this is like one of the best fucking rounds i've had you're welcome
teammates i dropped it because i thought it was closing oh no sorry oh i did i'm still surprised
that it's so well there
oh my god what happens if i win on my last one though feels good man
you're telling me there is a time where's emi's out on twitter is it emi bizou not not so forward
hold on sorry i gotta see it it must be trending which is good though level over oh i've got it
oh she has 20 oh fuck oh my god she also has a million impressions she has half a million
impressions on her bomb audio oh what the fuck oh my god that's fantastic though
okay sorry right i'm back to focus then i'm back to focus then i'll check it out after
this one i'll read some marshmallows if there's any okay this is called full tilt i've actually
made it past the round one joes sorry for the chopped piggyback
okay okay my teammates on the other side of the freaking map literally
hi teammate from over there okay i'm tryharding i'm actually tryharding
okay thanks
okay okay easy easy okay i fell down there but i actually worked out in the end somehow
oh wow okay okay okay i'm doing it me and my teammate i don't know who you are but
we're doing it and do you want to piggyback not right now we're gonna get in trouble
whoa whoa
very dangerous maneuver i don't know how i got away with that i still don't see my teammate though
okay we're gonna have to go on this side okay no you actually just counterpointed me thank you
replaying you know who you are i couldn't read your name in time i'm sorry oh he's literally
can't even point at me you're helping me refling thank you whoa okay i did it i did it from a
squad i did it from a squad who the heck is my squad mate though who's my squad mate
oh it's okay it's okay
okay it's okay you can do it i believe in you no pressure
no pressure you can just focus on the objective and we can do it oh and we can get
nicely rolled back there it's okay no yes yes yes
yes wow you did it you did it we did it you did it glad to hear games for strutting oh my god they
actually are though thumbs up or thumbs down oh you did it replaying you clutched up okay
we all demonstrate ourselves sometimes in teams against others sometimes against each other and
then we all talk in the stands team managed fog mommy are you going crazy smurfing have a play
egg scramble oh no what's the grab button i've already forgot uh use right trigger to grab
okay right trigger to grab an item put the most eggs in your team's basket oh god what color am i
i am yellow i'm yellow abadi abadi i'm yellow abadi abadi okay oh i miss oh sorry i'm grabbing
the teeth oh did you hold it
okay get that in there love them eggs in there i want them fertilized by the morning do you
understand me reeflings okay now you ain't come from the red team fuck the red team
team fuck you red team this is what we think about you oh shit okay
okay okay we need steel from the red team
you can't do nothing about a wings fuck you that's my egg now there is nothing you can do about a
red team okay oh my god no let go this is my egg there are many eggs in this world no stop it
you're stealing stop being stinky stinky you're so stinky haha get right you can't deal with it
the blue team blue team just admit defeat okay
blue team give up oh you let that go that's mine don't get too cocky now don't get too cocky
yellow team don't get too cocky we're trying get off me back off be gone okay okay yank
and throw it no don't get right the red team's catching up the red team's catching up a little
hold on we've got nine seconds surely we'll we've got it done surely oh there's just eggs in the
middle of the map we don't even need to go into the nests so you're stealing strongy the thief
honestly egg maxing by the morning they have been fertilized the moment you took them on your hand
we're doing it we're doing it we're doing it have we may actually win why is your red and yellow
gang it up on blue i take the red it's always like fuck the reds okay team tail hi okay press
right trigger to grab the tail got it the blue team was actually tossing yet eggs into yellow
oh were you that makes sense because i was like why aren't the blue having anything
uh that makes oh i'm green now heck yeah oh no i'm blue sorry i'm blue abadi abadi right i'm coming
for right i can see recon's the closest to me so i'm going for him give me that tail oh what the
fuck oh i'm falling wait you're actually giving me a come back oh come back i need a tail
uh i need a tail hello hello you need to give it to me i'm gonna lose oh shit okay that's good
okay hold on how do oh i'm like i'm proper losing oh oh my god i have a tail
okay that worked kind of okay that's fine
wait that's my teammate i'm blue wait you come here
i'm stealing i'm thieving i'm thieving okay i might just do this this is safety and leave me alone
i see every no no that didn't count you were so not close who was it you that took it how do you
come back here right now that's right that's what i thought no no no no no at least at least let me
have it for a little bit i mean it feels good and stuff stop stop i'm gonna lose no get him
um oh no oh no are we gonna win okay i'm not just i'm not just hanging out here
oh my god we did it we're actually gonna win i think we're gonna win
this trony's gonna take the blood oh my god we're doing it what's next
oh no oh no what is it is that an obstacle course i think snowball survival try not to
break the ace and don't fall out the ball shrill and you really went from the pocket star you're
the closest i was like give me it stroney woke up one day and decided red has no egg race in the
last match you have this i've never played this one before but i've seen you guys play it so surely
it's gonna go fain surely don't call me surely right i just need to survive the acicles wherever
they're coming from oh there that cannon up there let the cannons up there we fling i can't jump on
your back aren't you gonna get us both get up well sure you can come along why not sure come along
for the raid list i'm gonna end up ending as both i'm not even kidding thanks as if you're saying
thanks i'm gonna get us both killed you're literally throwing for your pretty mate uh uh
right okay hold on i'm trying to like predict for the heck this is going
i'm just staying away from it i'm just staying away
okay okay
okay i'm looking i'm looking
don't worry don't worry i got it so we can do this nice and simple
easy that's okay we did it whoa we did it we actually did it oh my gosh
oh is he an eggplant oh you humping me did anyone oh i guess it wasn't that hard then
if no one perished okay
that refling literally you
congrats refling you everywhere everyone lives literally it wasn't that hard right the slain
score rapper uh outrun the rising slime and survive through the obstacles to reach the finish
line oh i've not played this version of it uh this is looking a bit intense what is still going on
it's so big why it doesn't have to be right run from the slime don't don't wait about you need to
run from the slime go go go go check this out oh yeah oh how does this oh okay oh okay i understand
a little bit okay wait let's just do this jump oh my god right okay i'm under i'm i'm getting it
is this is this open no oh it does it opens right when i move away from it of course it does
because why would it open when i was next to it smile okay let's just be super
different safe uh i don't like this i don't like it at all oh no oh no that's such a shame
i was actually not doing too bad ah it was the first time playing it so i'm not that mad honestly
that map's quite confusing i was like uh going to the blue question mark
you got this oh i'm so good but it's okay it's okay right maybe my gen mate my gen mate
my duo is still alive my gen mate is live she be we're gonna redirect into her in a second
are you still up oh no you perished didn't you my teammate perished oh no
oh well we're out we're out that was good progress eggplant and gentek confirmed
but kupa is getting absolutely smacked about by these disco lights he's had enough
he's trying he's going for it aw
you did well cuddles hey yeah eliminated that's okay though we tried our best
but the slime was too much now you guys know see now you secretly know why i don't like slime girls
because of this game wink wink
you're fine slime is evil exactly the deepest lore has been unlocked final run
tip-toe finale oh work together to race across the tiles to reach the crown first
be safe little c we'd be careful for you aw you be safe to be fling you have to look after yourself
strony's evil origin story oh it's okay little sister's giving us all the slime we need
strony got overwhelmed by a slim girl confirmed well what is this i've never seen it
oh oh um
okay okay okay we've got progress on this team what's happening over here
uh what does the button do
i have no idea what the button does
it's shaking panels why would you shake panels
oh it's shooting stuff i don't i'm too dumb to understand
uh how are our blutes oh no it's not blinking
how far are you getting
the game said to walk in pairs
oh oh
oh good guess so
how's the other team looking oh wow
okay so you have to go together struggling hard with those shaky panels yeah i don't
know do they throw you off
must be left side for you guys no
you've already done that one you silly you silly billy
it's like squid game with glass platforms yeah
you guys need to go left side you've done right side have you not am i going crazy
sorry i maybe shouldn't backseat game honestly i have oh no i have nothing but the audacity of
backseat game noob lord and solid blade congrats on winning yabba sorry i shouldn't backseat
game i didn't mean to confuse you sorry that was me i shouldn't have backseat games i know me
okay right we'll leave it there because that's fantastic i'm gonna check if there's any marshmallows
wait let me put my background music on so it's not just like deaf and oh i don't even have my
background music where's my background music uh where is this are you got my background music
nope you don't wait that'll do it then i didn't have it i don't know why i don't have it okay
you're just gonna have to listen to my voice and nothing else okay i'll just check if there's any
marshmallows any marshmallows
that was like such good gg's that was so fun you guys did amazing
okay there's a few marshmallows in front of him
what the fuck is this
oh love let me tell you how much i've come to love you since debut there are 387.44 million
miles of skin and tentacles and wafers and layers that fill my body and the world love
that was engraved on each nano nano strong of the hundreds of millions of miles that would not equal
one one billionth of the love i feel at this micro instant frustrony love love i'm so sorry
i couldn't freaking answer like read that properly but i love you to a little refill and i'm glad
to yet you're enjoying yourself hopefully i think that's what that meant i had no idea what that meant
but i think it means it's good so it says messy or reynaldo
okay i blinked uh i can't keep up with the litness of the
fellow reeflings so wholesome marrow this is i'd like to hug mommy kiss you on the cheek
and thank you for the fun time she's given us too much love much love little reeflin sorry if
we're a little too h-word like we've been pan up okay a little bit pan up but we have good news soon
yellow mummy why am i yellow yellow mummy another reefling had an idea of an audio where
we the reeflings were trying to impress you by being really good at video games but then
you decide to tease us by being the big spoon and give us a hand while you're playing the game
i don't know if this would be a good prompt for an audio but i think it makes a good idea remember
to get plenty of rest my beloved as the as the coconut says my beloved
oh yellow oh i was like why yellow my liver is doing just fine
hi strongy as a little more fucker i really enjoyed the stream today hey don't mention it we do
stream sniping every week you can always hang out or you can always lurk please don't ever feel forced
to talk and chat i know some some strawmers are like lurking bad no lurking good you're welcome
to lurk as much as you please please don't ever feel forced to talk that's not nice feeling put
on the spot whimper oh oh the whimpering coconut i forgot um strongy i just want to say i love you
so much that alternative outfit idea talking is gonna leave me feral for you i can't wait to see it
i need to see the refling literally be attached to your hips like that love you love you to refling
i'm glad you like the idea because it's pretty it's not gonna i'm sure as someone an outsider
that wouldn't consume the content they'd just be like oh it's just like tentacles wrapping around
and it's like all of us who know exactly what it means um i'm really happy when you said you
like butter is there any possibility for a future one no unfortunately it's against the
rules so i can't do anything with it it's all good in me right now i just lurk and tip oh spidey
thank you for the lurk and the tip i appreciate it yeah please don't ever feel forced to like
bing a chat or anything like that i don't like that um what are we known
uh so sorry strongy i should have worried my question i'm a little rarted today oh don't
worry about it i'm rarted every day it's fine i literally can't read or write so don't worry about
it yeah don't feel embarrassed or anything like that um put this up and tagged it after the sweet
stream but i know you're being flooded i don't want to know anyone by tagging for a profit here
wait what are you squidding me right now i'm going to have to look at a pp like on stream
i lurk and tip during work hours smile broly legend thank you for this tip oh what i missed an artwork
i think you're are you massaging my feet
i miss an artwork oh kfp spidey thank you for the five gifted memberships as well congrats to
those who caught it with your face wow wait i missed an artwork start slow okay and then
reefling makes wet noises and be gentle hey i said be gentle dumber that's the sport sensitive
and then i go uh and then it says golem noises where did i miss this oh it's got my bbp
oh my god it's so accurate you know
gifting because i won oh did you win boy thank you for the gifted and congrats to those who caught
it with their face
sense fancy lol me dodging those gifted subs like new in the matrix um all part of the
all part of the things you make me want to do do the most urge i have right now is to hug you
hope you feel better and that won't ruin your time when you're dead no no no it's fine literally
i'll feel better and like i kid you not 40 hours i'm gonna feel exactly like myself again a stress
type angel but missed i know that feeling um hey stroney i had a thought and i like to extend
the idea i don't know how much you'll be oh wait i've read that one okay i'm on call
just like that i'm all caught up i'm so good at this honestly okay there's new ones
if it's fun playing the bean game next time we should play among us heck yeah i'm done for
among us i need to devour your doughnut
oh what did he and now are you sure we flin right now
right now
uh you asked me earlier about my mario if maro if i was pent up dancers yes i am very for you
good refling the way i like it i like when competition is fierce
not him but yeah i can i can't sweat as bad among us oh i'm gonna start shouting at you
um
um hi stroney i love you i have this thing where i always think about you i almost called it a
problem but i realized it's great thank you for being you have i corrupted you i've not even had
one hypnosis audio out yet literally i've been out the gates for a month and i've still not done
an audio where i break you can't believe it fake hypno person oh i'm so fake
love you too little refling glad i could break you in
just imagine what will happen when i actually try and do it to you you know
um imagine we were both inside a fall guy's suit like a big mascot we could do it in public
and no one would ever know refling we're not humping in a fall guy's suit outside i like your
enthusiasm i like your creativity but we're not both going to jump in a fall guy's suit
go outside and hump hump hump wait you're not trying yet why not why would we go inside a fall guy's
suit at anything anything and you pick the jellybean suit you don't want me to cosplay as like to be
or you don't want to cosplay as rebecca from fucking age runners you don't want me to cosplay
as like i don't know jinks or something you want me to be in a jellybean suit with you
alright no we want jellybean okay you're done i will part your red seat a man loves his women
every day of the month oh my god refling that's funny as fuck
uh all the way to go Moses that guy a real one that's terrible right i'm gonna redirect into
sheebie thank you so much for understanding and knowing that um
hold on sorry someone's been at it in the comments sorry um thank you so so much for
understanding that i need a wee bit of time to recover i'm happy to say i don't have any heart
murmurs anymore so i think i was just severely dehydrated oh to be a woman fuck it i hate it
honestly don't do it okay we're gonna redirect into sheebie cotton bomb
please subscribe to all my gen mate smile thank you so much for all the memberships
all the ridiculous tips and super chats and what have you okay but first of all you need to
puck her up don't you did you like that yeah you like that admit it you like that
okay i see you goofy goobers tomorrow oh god i got disconnected from the server because i've
been memeing a bit too long okay i'm going to success successfully redirect into sheebie cotton
bomb please enjoy her ASMR it might be a bit more tame it's not the same without the jelly beans
so you're done okay i'll see you goofy goobers tomorrow for whatever's planned tomorrow i have
genuinely no idea what i plan tomorrow but that's the fun of it because we get to do it tomorrow
right i'll see you guys tomorrow bye bye bye we things okay one extra kiss